javascript gives us specific
capabilities to perform any website
related tasks including designing the
front end and working on the back end of
any website
this is just one of the numerous factors
contributing to javascript's appeal in
hello everyone and welcome to simply
learn's youtube channel
i hope you guys are doing well today
we'll be taking you through the
javascript tutorial for beginners we'll
cover everything in this video from
basics to some advanced level javascript
topics don't worry if you are a newbie
or if you are an advanced level
developer this video will certainly help
you in different tasks but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple technology
videos so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and press that bell icon
to never miss any updates from simply
learn
let's go through the agenda for today's
video we'll start this video by
understanding what javascript is
following that we'll cover the most
important topics of javascript which are
reasons to learn javascript what is
document object model how to install vs
code hello world program in javascript
javascript statements and comments
variables in javascript following that
we'll move ahead and cover topics like
strings and arrays in javascript once we
are done with the basic topics we'll
move ahead and cover some advanced level
topics of javascript which are objects
in javascript classes and inheritance in
javascript callback functions in
javascript promises javascript arrow
functions timing functions in javascript
and then we'll cover async await in
javascript
error handling in javascript regular
expressions in javascript form
validation in javascript
and then finally we'll cover animation
in javascript we'll work on certain
projects to end this video we'll create
a world game and a functional website
using html css and javascript
it is rightly said that you can master a
programming language just by programming
in it i hope you guys are ready to learn
something new today so without any
further ado let's start with the first
topic for the day
javascript was developed in the year
by a person named brendan ike
brendan was working for netscape
communications while he developed
javascript in 10 days
there were a few changes in the name of
javascript initially it was moca which
was later changed to live script and
then it finally became javascript
the start of javascript wasn't that good
as so many developers who were using
java at that time
they considered javascript as a language
for designers and non-engineers
no one ever knew that this small side
scripting language would have a great
future today more than 90 percent of the
websites out there they are using
javascript somehow many of you guys gets
confused with java and javascript
let me clear it for you that both java
and javascript they are different
languages they have almost nothing in
common
many people say that javascript was
named after java as a part of a
marketing strategy to gain wider
acceptance and recognition
in 1995 java was a buzzword when
javascript was developed that's why they
renamed javascript after java let's move
on to what is javascript
have you guys ever been through a
website where you can see images that
slides automatically one such website is
amazon the home page of amazon where we
can see different types of ongoing sales
is an example of javascript
in layman language javascript is a
lightweight scripting language used to
make web pages more interactive and more
lively earlier when javascript was
developed it was only a side scripting
language to do basic tasks like you can
add pop-ups in your web page or you can
make your web page more interactive
nothing more than that but now the whole
scenario has changed with the help of
javascript we can create applications as
well
if we talk about applications let's take
an example let's suppose we want to
create an app we can create it in
android or in ios but we have to learn
few different languages to create those
apps for android we have to learn java
and xml and swift we have to learn for
ios but with the help of javascript you
can create hybrid applications which can
work on any platform without any problem
tech giants like google paypal amazon
and youtube they are using javascript
these days the evolution of javascript
in the past few years was unbelievable
suppose you want to create a single page
website every one of us is familiar with
gmail let's suppose so gmail is a single
page website which looks more like a
desktop software than a website so gmail
is based on angular.js
it is a popular framework by google
which is free of cost and it is totally
based on javascript now let's go over
some of the features of javascript these
features are actually why it is
considered that using javascript is
advantageous over other languages
so let's start with some of these points
javascript is not a proper programming
language indeed it is a scripting
language
which works in the runtime environment
just like python so there are few other
languages like c plus plus and java they
need a compiler to work but with
javascript you don't need a compiler
once you are done with the script it
will interpret and show you the output
in the browser directly
next up is light weighted javascript can
provide programming facility to some
extent in javascript you don't need to
specify any data type or return type
which helps in making development more
quicker that's why it is known as light
weighted
javascript is both client-side as well
as server side technology client-side
technology runs on the user's computer
whereas the server-side technology runs
on the web browser initially when
javascript was introduced it was
introduced as a client-side technology
but with the introduction of node.js in
2009 one can now work in the back end as
well
there is a way to validate the user's
data before sending it to the web server
and we can do that with the help of
javascript the data will be checked for
correct form and value
all we have to do is start a loop give
it the condition
to check the data javascript is also
platform independent although originally
designed to work on browsers only but
now it is a platform independent
language which means once you are done
with the script you can use it on any
browser or platform without any problem
javascript is an object based scripting
language although many programmers do
not consider javascript as a true object
oriented programming language due to its
lack of class concept
it does support other features of object
oriented programming like it supports
encapsulation it supports polymorphism
and also it supports prototypal
inheritance
the last but not the least feature of
javascript is case sensitive so when it
comes to keywords identifiers names and
functions javascript differentiates
between capital and lowercase letters we
have to keep this in mind while
programming
now i will quickly go over some of the
javascript applications where javascript
is currently being implemented
first one that comes to every person's
mind is web development it was also the
main motive behind developing javascript
we have technologies like angular we
have node.js we can create beautiful web
pages
also javascript can be used along with
html and css to make those static
looking web pages more engaging if we
talk about other applications of
javascript we can use it in app
development either mobile app or web app
like we took the example before that how
hybrid apps made with the help of
javascript can take over traditional
android and ios app
one of the most important and unique
application of javascript is in smart
watches the bengal.js is an open sourced
smartwatch powered by javascript gordon
williams the man who is currently
working on this project it is said that
this new open sourced stack built around
javascript will replace the onboard
firmware soon the next application of
javascript is client-side validation as
we discussed earlier javascript is used
to validate the user data whether the
user's input is correct or not by cross
checking it with the given condition
like the user wants to enter in your
website and you want it to be a user
with at the right gmail.com in his email
id so you will give that condition to
javascript and it will cross check it
with the user's information like when
the user will try to enter in your
website it will check that if at the
rate gmail.com is there or not in the
user's email id
so it can validate the user also apart
from that one more application of
javascript is game development
javascript can be used to make fully
fledged 2d or 3d games using different
libraries although most javascript game
development focuses on creating games
used in browsers only
till now we have an idea about what
javascript is its features and its
applications so if you want to learn
javascript you need to do some basic
things to make your learning experience
more smoother let's take a look at the
prerequisites to use javascript the
first one is the basic knowledge of html
and css to use javascript along with
html and css you first need to know how
html and css works see html is used to
create the structure of a web page while
css is used to style that web page in
order to use these two with javascript
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css because if you want to
learn a new language first of all you
need to know why to use that technology
and to learn javascript more efficiently
you need to have the basic knowledge of
html and css
it's better to have a web browser that
supports javascript like google chrome
or mozilla firefox or you can use safari
as well if you are using a macbook you
will need an operating system like
windows linux or mac operating system to
learn javascript a computer with minimum
mb of ram would be enough for you to
start learning javascript but i will
recommend you a computer with 1gb of ram
or 4gb of ram for a better experience
you can use any text editor you have
notepad which is free and is already
available for windows
if you don't want to use notepad you can
use other free softwares like sublime or
you can use visual code in this
particular course we will be using
visual code and i'll tell you how to
install visual code and what are the
features of visual code also suppose you
do not have any prior knowledge about
javascript don't worry about it we will
take you through the whole course and we
will ensure that you can understand
javascript let's start this video with
some facts about javascript
javascript is the only programming
language that a browser can understand
25 years ago when developers were
thinking about a language that a browser
can understand
there were a few languages that were
present in the market at that time just
like java still there were some problems
with these languages that these
languages need a server to work with the
browser javascript on the other hand can
work directly with the browser you write
the code in the editor the browser will
go through it it will interpret it and
then runs the program
the popularity of javascript increased
with time
being a language which can do so many
tasks whether it be designing a
website's front end or going through any
websites back-end javascript can do
anything by the end of 2018 over 95
percent of the internet was powered by
javascript means almost every website
out there is using javascript in some
way or another
do you guys know about stack overflow a
website for every programmer don't worry
you will get to know about it once you
start with the programming part stack
overflow states that javascript is the
most popular programming language used
by the developers let me quickly run you
through the reasons why one should learn
javascript and then we'll briefly
elaborate each of these reasons
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks
javascript is constantly growing and is
a well-paid job
javascript is beginner friendly and it
has the largest community
javascript provides wide range of usage
as well
let's move on further and see
why each of these reason is important
javascript has the most powerful
frameworks for every task a user wants
to do like for designing a single page
website like you want to
design a website like gmail you can use
angular.js if you want to design ui
components or user interfaces for single
page application you have react.js you
want to develop a mobile or a desktop
application let's suppose you have
view.js for that as well basically you
can do anything with powerful javascript
frameworks
next up is constant truth one of the
main reasons behind one should learn
javascript javascript is one of the
fastest growing languages and stands
among the top 10 languages used by the
developers with so much increase in
mobile market mobile web development has
seen an immense rise in need of
interactivity
which is possible only with the help of
javascript
that's why javascript is continuously
growing and there is no way that
javascript will go down shortly
the developers working in javascript are
well paid across the world anyone who
wants to be a web designer or a web
developer needs to learn javascript
it is a must have skill for being a good
web developer we will discuss it in
javascript jobs section
javascript is an easy to learn language
compared to many other programming
languages
like java python and php javascript
provides easy entry points to the world
of programming the best thing about
javascript is that it comes
pre-installed on almost every web
browser so you don't need to set up any
environment to start development in
javascript which means you can start
coding right away
javascript has the largest community
among all the programming languages out
there
community size does matter when it comes
to programming language because the
larger the community size is
the more help you would be likely to get
currently javascript has the biggest
stack overflow community it has
overtaken java in terms of community
size and is still growing at a rapid
pace wide range of usage in my opinion
one of the most important reasons why
one should learn javascript by knowing
javascript you can build an entire
website from its backend to the front
apart from that you can also build a
full flash mobile application for the
back end you don't need to learn other
programming languages node.js is enough
with a bit of knowledge about database
and apis there is nothing you can't do
with javascript when it comes to website
development
let's move on and discuss few jobs you
can take up after learning javascript
and we'll also discuss their average
salaries in usa and in india
so the first one is a full stack
developer a full stack developer is one
of the highest paid jobs in web
development sector a full stack
developer is equally proficient in
client side as well as server side
development a full stack developer earns
around 9 lakh per annum which is quite a
decent amount of money for a person
living in india but if you are a full
stack developer in u.s you can earn up
to 100 000 dollars per annum which is a
huge amount
a front-end developer is the one who
deals with the front end of any website
or application it's obvious that a
front-end developer will not earn as
much as a full stack developer
but the amount of money a front-end
developer earns in a year is decent
a javascript developer works on the
front end and sometimes back and also
a javascript developer may be
responsible for the whole website or
just a few aspects or pages of different
websites they earn quite well when it
comes to salary a js developer in u.s
earns around 75 000 per annum which when
converted to indian rupees sums around
55 lakhs approx which is a huge amount
designing a ui is an interesting job as
it needs creativity along with skills
it's always fun to design interfaces to
attract users one should need a lot of
creativity for this job the amount of
money a ui ux designer earns in india is
around 7 lakh per annum but it can go up
as much as 20 lakh per annum depends
upon the skills possessed and creativity
of the designer so choose your career
wisely let's start this video with the
introduction to dom
dom stands for document object model it
is an api for html and xml documents
which helps javascript to understand
what is there written inside the html
document api stands for application
programming interface to understand api
better let's take an example of a
restaurant
imagine yourself in the restaurant you
are sitting at the table with the menu
the chef in the kitchen is also part of
the system the waiter here works as a
messenger between you and the chef
that's what api does it works as a
moderator between javascript and the
html document
dom defines the whole html document in a
hierarchical form to make it
understandable for javascript so that
other javascript functions can work over
it
it represents the entire document in the
form of object and nodes
whether it be elements or text or
anything stored in the document the
entire page content can be accessed or
manipulated by javascript
dom is not used with javascript only
other languages like python also uses
dom dom was designed to be used
independently to begin with dom there is
nothing special you have to do different
browsers have different implementation
of the document object model
every browser uses dom to make the web
page of the document accessible by
javascript let's move on and see what is
document object model with the help of
an example
i believe you guys have the basic
knowledge of html and css a prerequisite
for this course let's start things off
with a basic html example here we have a
code that consists tags like html head
body heading tag etc we have the html
tag here the opening html tag and the
closing html tag
inside the html tag we have the head tag
which contains the document's header
part inside the head tag there is a
title tag that contains the title of the
web page then comes the body tag which
contains a heading tag and two div tags
with ids as div 1 and div 2. a div tag
defines a particular section in the html
document the id used within the div tag
it is an attribute basically that has to
be unique within the document to make
the element unique from other elements
next up we have a paragraph tag with a
class attribute within it css and
javascript uses classes to select and
access specific elements don't worry
guys if you have no idea about it
let us first see the output of this code
before going to the document object
model of this whole document so guys
this is the output of the previous code
we just came here we can see the title
of the web page as well as heading after
it there were two different div tags
used in the code here is the output of
both the div text the question here is
where are those id and class attributes
seen in the output the answer to this
question is there is nothing on this web
page that can show both of them we can
use them in our css file or through
javascript to specify the containers in
which they are used so we have concluded
how a normal document works and how the
browser interprets the html code but how
javascript uses this code is a bit
different that's where dom comes into
play when the actual html document is
loaded in the browser another
representation of that document is
created known as document object model
here's the model you can see on your
screen
each of the tags used in html document
is correspondingly represented as
objects in the dom
like starting from the html tag and
covering all the other tags like head
title body and few more
the same hierarchy as there was in the
html document goes with the document
object model also
document object model is simply the same
html document with different
representation
the reason behind this different
representation is that it's easy for
javascript to interpret this format
javascript can't understand tags but it
can understand these objects javascript
can easily manipulate these objects
using different functions which we will
see in future while working on these
functions for example if you want to
access the text present inside the
heading tag you can do it by accessing
the heading tag with javascript
you can also work on the style of this
text with the help of javascript as well
javascript uses the concept of nodes it
can access nodes of the document object
model there are many types of nodes
present in the dom the basic three types
are element node attribute node and text
mode the element node consists of all
the tags used in html document like the
head tag and the body tag
the attribute node contains the
attributes used in html document by now
i hope you have understood the concept
of attributes so javascript can access
these attributes as well and the user
can work upon them as per requirements
the text here in the html document that
is simply
it can also be accessed with the help of
javascript it is the value of that
particular element before installing vs
code let's discuss a few things about
what is an ide
so ide stands for integrated development
environment it is a software application
basically it comprehends facilities to a
programmer for software development just
like photoshop makes it easier for us to
edit photos in the same way ide makes it
easier for a programmer to write code if
you want to write code ide will help you
write that and it will help you in
software development
there are a number of ides present in
the market today we have sublime we have
pycharm we have comodo we have notepad
and notepad plus plus as well but in
this particular course we will be using
visual studio code or vs code we can say
so let me run you through some of the
advantages that why we are using vs code
for this course so first of all vs code
is free to use as it is an open source
software so you can use it without any
cost
it supports multiple programming
languages there is nothing like you need
any web support or work on different
editors for different programming you
can use vs code for different languages
extensions are also one of the main
reasons behind using vs code see you
want to work on a programming language
it does not support all you have to do
is add an extension search for it and
you are good to go it will also not
affect the speed of the editor as it
runs as a different process it can also
detect code snippet whether it is
complete or not like you are using a
variable in your program and you forgot
to declare it
vs code will do it for you this property
is known as intellisense
besides all these properties one main
key feature behind using vs code is it
is cross platform it is available for
mac it is available for linux and
windows as well i think there are enough
features we have discussed till now
there are many more features we will
discuss them while installing or while
working in vs code so for now let's move
on to the installation process the
installation process for vs code is
pretty simple just go to google and
search for vs code the next page which
will open here you can see that the
first link available is from the
official website click on that and you
will go to their official website here
in the front you can see the download
this you can download the stable version
from here only
or if you want to download it for you
according to your pc's specifications
you can click on the download button
present at the top right corner of your
screen here you can see that vs code is
available for different platforms it is
available for windows for linux and for
mac as well you can download it from
here as well so if you want to download
it for windows you can click here
it will take you to another page and it
will start downloading vs once the
download completes open the setup file
from your downloads and it will take you
to the license agreement page you have
to agree with all the terms and
conditions you can go through the full
license but then it will take a lot of
time to go through all this once you
click on it
this window will open where you have to
select the location you want your vs
code to locate
any id you install the default location
for all the editors is the same you can
click on browse and select any other
location if you want
but for now i'll be leaving it as it is
and i'll click on next now this will
open and you will click next from here
now it will ask you some questions like
if you want to create a desktop icon or
not select all of them and click on next
now click on install and it will install
vs code for you sit back and relax it
will take time so once you are done with
the installation process click on finish
and the visual studio code will start
automatically
so here we are you can see that we are
on the welcome page so let's start with
these icon present on the left side of
the editor this icon here is explorer so
vs code works with the folders in your
system click on open folder and just
search any folder or you can take any
folder of your choice so here in my pc
i'll go to work and i'll
take javascript as my folder i'll select
it and see it will open the folder and i
already have a few programs written over
here like this
and i have a few more programs like this
and this
you can open any program from that
folder by using this explorer option you
can open any program present in that
folder so basically what it does any
program you make in visual studio code
you will save it in this folder only so
it will be easy for you
to open any program anytime next up we
have the search button
to find any keyword or word present in
your code whatever you write here it
will show you where it is present in
your code or in your document
so let's suppose i write here simply
learn see it will show you simply learn
in your main screen so you have a
shortcut key for this also press control
plus f from your keyboard and write
anything here like it's written simply
linear press enter and it will show you
the result the third option here is for
version control if you want to use any
version control like you want to use git
vs code has very good integration with
kit the next button here is for debug or
it will run your program once you are
done with writing the code click here
and run and debug just open it with
chrome you have a shortcut for this as
well press f5 from your keyboard and it
will do the same the next button here is
for extensions here you can find many
extensions given by the vs code
community they are free to use
for now
we will use these three extensions the
first one is html css support just click
on the search button write html css
support the first option click on that
and install that extension similarly you
have to install few more you have to
install javascript and type script
nightly
and you have to install live server in
the same way i'll tell you the use of
live server in the next video when we
will be writing our first hello world
program let me end this video by giving
you a shortcut let's create a new file
here click here create a new file
just
close it create a new file we will name
it as
new
dot html
so it's new.html here one thing you have
to keep in mind
while saving a file make sure to save
that file with dot html extension here
we are about to start writing our first
program so just write
exclamation mark and press enter
it will do this see it will write the
basic html code which you will need in
almost every program from now on so you
don't have to write this code every time
just do it this way and start writing
main program we are using vs code studio
as a text editor to write the script
here we have already discussed the
benefits as well as the features of vs
code in the previous video so as i have
already mentioned you must have a web
browser with javascript enabled in it so
if you are using google chrome it's
quite easy to enable javascript let me
take you through it open google chrome
go to settings and just write javascript
in the search option go to site settings
and scroll down you will find here
javascript allow it if it's not allowed
in my case it's already allowed so i'm
good to go
once you have downloaded the editor and
you are done with the environment setup
and all you can start writing the
program so let's go
to escort we will open a new file here
and save it with the name let's open a
new file and we will save it with name
first dot html make sure to save your
file with dot html extension as it will
make it easy for the computer to
understand that this particular file is
an html file so
in the last video we installed an
extension named live server let me tell
you how to use it and what are the
benefits of using live server so let's
write a basic html program or
just press the exclamation key and press
enter here we are with the basic html
program
we have not done anything yet just edit
it a little bit we will add a heading
tag and inside the heading tag we will
write a heading let's suppose we are
writing
hello
so now right click on your desktop and
click on open with live server
what this will do it will open your
program in the browser see it's the
basic thing so let me tell you what its
benefits are it will open your program
in the browser and whatever changes you
are making in the programs will be
directly shown in the browser the moment
you save them see
just use google chrome or whatever
browser you are using
and in the vs code side by side we will
be using it side by side now
let's suppose we'll change something
here let's add a word here hello
world and the moment we save it it will
be reflected in your browser as well so
that's the benefit of using live server
we will be using it during our whole
code so now we are done with that let's
start with the program so here we are
with our basic html code which has only
tags in it it will print that thing if i
remove this heading tag let me remove it
and movement i save it it will print
nothing
so guys let me give you a brief
introduction to these tags these html
tags are used to render html files
properties so that the browser can
differentiate between simple text and
html tags
you can use as many tags according to
your requirements in our first program
we will write a single line statement
over the browser for that we will need
the script tag don't worry if you don't
know much about script tag
let me tell you briefly about this text
functionality it is used to embed a
client-side script language remember
guys script tag is used to embed
javascript with html this is where html
and javascript comes together
it may contain the scripting statements
or point towards the external script
through the src attribute we will see
the src attribute as well we'll use the
script tag inside the body tag or we can
use it wherever we want to use it like
it's not necessary to use it inside the
body tag only we can use it anywhere in
our program so let's start with this
first
let's start the scripted
we are done with it now the script tag
we have to type an attribute
the attribute is the type is it's a text
file
we are done with our script tag to write
on the web page we use a very basic
command the document.write
it is a javascript method using which
you can print anything on the browser
let's see what document.write can do
let's write here something
document.write
and any text you want to write inside it
let's suppose hello world
welcome to
simply code
so guys we are done with this we have
written a text over here hello world
welcome to simply code let's see what
will happen when we save it
press ctrl s and the moment you save it
here it will be reflected on your
browser here you can see in our browser
it's written over here hello world
welcome to simplico we can define
javascript in an external file as well
let's see how we can do this how this
script tag will point towards an
external javascript file here what you
have to do you have written script just
before type use an attribute src and
give it the source of the file but till
now we don't have any javascript file so
let's create a file first name it as
script.js remember you have to save it
with dot js extension we are done with
it and we are good to go so here we will
write document
dot right
and any text you want to write here
hello world welcome to
simply learn
we will save it the moment we will save
it here
there's something wrong i guess
okay we have not given the source code
of that javascript so here we have to
give the name of that file it was script
dot js
moment we will save it see the text has
changed here
initially it was hello world welcome to
simply code but now it is hello world
welcome to simply learn
this document.write is not interpreted
by the browser that's because this
script tag is now pointing towards an
external javascript file anything you
will write inside this script tag will
not be considered now so we are done
with this script tag here we now have an
idea of how to embed javascript with
html and now let's see some of the
features of document.write
so let's suppose you are you have
written this text here let's erase it
and see what else it can do let's give
it a task to add two numbers let's
suppose we have given here 9 plus 3
let's see if it works
see
it will give you the output directly
here
document.9 plus 3 it will give you the
output as 12. similarly you will do
any mathematical task any calculation
you want to do
let's suppose
7 multiply by 8
see
you can see here 12 56 square let's
give it another one 9 multiply 5 minus
let's suppose 3 and save it see 9 into 5
is 45 and if you minus 3 from 45 you
will get 42 here is the answer for s 42
56 is for 7 into 8 7 multiplied by 8 and
12 is for 9 plus 3
so with that we are done with how to
embed with javascript with html let's
move on to another concept in javascript
that is console.log console.log is a
function in javascript that works the
same as document.write
but it will not print anything in the
browser let's give it a try
let's
clear this and suppose we write here
console.log
and give it a command
save it and see there is nothing printed
on the browser let's write something in
the body tag we'll use a heading tag and
write something here let's go again and
go to body tag we'll use a heading tag
here as well
and write something here let's suppose
we write
click code
save it see this is printed on the
browser to open your browser's console
go to browser right click here and go to
inspect element or you can use control
plus shift plus i which i normally do
here you can see the console option see
it has many options like elements
consoles sources network and many more
but for now let's focus on console here
you can see the text printed here so
what's the point of doing this whenever
we write a code we usually have many
variables and functions and a lot of
these kinds of things
we don't always know what to expect as
the output maybe we expect a particular
result but we might get something else
one way of debugging our code is that we
can pass a value to this function here
only and we can check the result of that
value out of the code let's add two
numbers here so if you don't understand
it basically what we are doing for now
we are writing a small piece of code
like the program is not that big but
later on when we are good with
javascript and we will use javascript as
a primary language the size of the
program will go longer and longer so not
every time you are supposed to
check the output of your code by doing
that only so if you are using any
variables or you are using any functions
you can check the output here only if
you have to use that variable in that
way or you have to change something so
you will get it here only that's the use
of console.log
let's add two numbers
and remove it a is equal to 5 and let
these value is 8
suppose
okay we are done with these two numbers
and we will what we will do we will
write
console.log
we have given it the command to add a
and b
let's see if it works here
see the value of a plus b is 13. you can
see it here in console the value is 13
you can see it here so here we can see
that the output is
13 you can do any complex calculation
here in the console it will give you the
correct answer you can see here
script.js colon 4 the number after the
column is the line in script.js here in
our file we can see that the console.log
command is in line number four so here
it is written that it is line number
four here so if you click on this
you can see
the script.js opened in a very small
window and you can edit it from here as
well so this is not a random line number
to prove this let's go on to a program
and let's move this to another line see
now the console.log is in line 11.
save it and here you can see this also
changed to 11 so let's make this more
complex add another variable c we'll add
another variable here let suppose we add
c here we'll give it a more complex
equation let's suppose
let c equals to
the moment we save it it will give it
the answer
oh no we are done with the equation
let's change it here also
the value of
c is
let's see if it works or not press
control plus s it's saved and the value
of c is 7. let's see if this value is
correct or not the value of a was 5 5
into 3 is 15
15 plus 8 is 23 23 plus 4 is 27
plus
a minus 25 value of a is 5 minus 25 is
minus 20
27 minus 20 the value of c is 7 say it's
correct
check it yourself if you can do
something more interesting with this
console.log or you can do something more
interesting with document.write
so console.log allows us to debug our
code and we can use it if we are not
sure about the output in a lengthy
program in the previous video we learned
about a first javascript program i
explained you some basic things like if
you want to perform addition if you want
to add two numbers or you want to
perform subtractions and multiplication
and division as well
before moving forward to statements and
comments here to take a note
while you are performing any
calculation let me show you
see if you are performing any
calculation let's
copy it from here and paste it here
so yeah if you want to perform and let's
add two numbers like we want to add 45
and
we'll add
let's say 5
we'll save it and here you can see the
answer is 50 here right
so if you want to perform any
calculation you have to write as it is
you can't write any calculation within
inverted comma or double inverted comma
let's try this if you want to write any
calculation within a single inverted
comma the moment you save it it will
print it as 45 plus 5 what the browser
will do the browser will interpret it as
text and print it as it is so there will
be no change so keep that in mind take a
note of it and we are done with it right
now
so let's move on to statements in
javascript so guys whenever you use any
programming language you give the
computer
some instruction to perform any task or
activity that's common in all
programming languages present out there
like you are giving computers a few
instructions to do a particular task
these instructions you are giving to the
computer are known as statements you see
the code written over here this
document.write function is an
instruction or statement given to the
computer to write something on the
browser like if you are writing hello
world inside this function it will print
it in the browser as it is
and same for addition subtraction
multiplication and whatever you are
writing inside it it will basically
print it on browser like let's suppose
if we write here something else
let's suppose we write here inside
uh double
inverted comma
welcome to simply code we save it we are
basically giving it the instruction to
write this on the browser so what it
will do it will write it as it is on the
browser these are the instructions we
are giving to a machine to perform a
basic task or to perform a certain task
so if you are writing a whole program
for designing a website or for anything
you must be using more than one
statement you will use a lot of
statements in a single program
so all these statements are separated by
semicolons like here you can see after
every statement i have written a
semicolon it's necessary let me show you
an example see we'll remove this
statement and we'll copy this line and
paste it in the next line and write
something else here but we can say
this is our first program we will write
like suppose i've written it i'll give
it the semicolon here the moment i'll
save it see you can see here it's
written that hello world the first
statement statement is interpreted and
written over here then second it come to
welcome to simply code see here you can
see that i have not written any semi
colon but it's still showing the output
so
let me tell you something interesting
so if you remove the semicolon from any
of these statement here it will work
fine which means javascript will forgive
you for these small errors you do but
it's always a good practice to put a
semi colon after every statement because
while writing a whole program in future
you will use n number of statements and
let's see what happen if you try to
write more than one statement in a
single line without any semicolon let's
do this thing here
write more than one statement in a
single line and i'll save it see it
won't work the moment i put a semicolon
here and save it
it will work fine so that's why i am
saying that it is a good practice to use
semicolon after each statement
hope you guys are getting this let's
move on to comments
so a comment is also common for almost
all programming languages it's a line in
programming language which do not have
any effect on the output of the program
see it stays there in the code but it
does not affect the output by any means
a comment may be a multi-line comment or
a single line comment as well to write a
single line comment we just use double
slash in front of that statement like
here if we see the output is hello world
welcome to simply code this is our first
program
so to make this first statement a
comment we what we'll do we'll use two
forward slashes in front of it and it
will become a comment so the moment we
will save it this hello world is
disappeared from the output
so this is how to use a single line
command a comment won't affect your
program by any means
let's move on to multi-line comments to
write a multiline comment you have to
use forward slash along with the
asterisk sign see if you want to make
these two lines as comments to end a
comment we will use astrix sign with a
forward slash
these two statements are comments now so
the moment you will save it welcome to
simply code is also disappeared from the
output that's how comment work
they won't affect your program's output
but comments are very useful in
programming it's just a note for the
programmers to remember what they did at
that particular part of the program
suppose you write a program see here the
programs are not that large and the
coding is not that much but in future
when you write a program maybe the
program will be of more than 500 lines
or more so suppose you write a program
with more than 500 lines and come back
20 days later so at that time you can't
go through the whole code this is where
comments will help you in javascript it
will help you to remember what you did
at that particular part of the program
so variables are named storage that a
program can manipulate as the name
suggests a variable is a value that can
change according to conditions variables
refers to those memory blocks inside the
computer where we can store information
let's suppose you want to store any
value inside your computer so variable
will represent the location of that
value
in simple terms variables are cups with
stuff inside them and you can use that
stuff later again and again according to
the way you want to before the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript
frequency which is the updated version
of javascript variables were declared
using a single keyword only which is
where we'll try to declare a few
variables here we'll see how where
keyword works so let's comment this
thing first
so let's declare a few variables let's
suppose where a equals to
15 will declare
where b and the value of b will be six
we will declare where
c and the value of c would be
a plus b so here we have defined three
variables a b and c
a is a variable with value 15 stored
inside it and so is b the value of b is
but c is a variable that will contain
the value of a plus b let's try to print
this on browser
document.write
and we will print the value of c
save it and here you can see the value
of c is 21
that's the correct answer so similarly
you can also print a and b as well let's
print a and b as well here
what we will do we will copy this line
we will paste it for
a and
we will update this here as well
so it won't create any confusion
so here you can see the value of c is 21
the value of a is 15 and the value of b
is 6. it shows the value of all the
three variables we declared but with the
introduction of es6 or ecmascript in
two more ways were introduced to declare
a variable these are let and const we
shall discuss these two terms in the
later part of this session let me show
you how to declare a variable there are
a few things you have to keep in mind
while declaring a variable name here we
have seen we use three variables a b and
c
that was an easy task to do but giving a
variable any name like something other
than a single alphabet so you have to
keep a few things in mind while naming
them start them with a letter underscore
or a dollar sign you can't use any sign
except underscore or dollar so if you
are
giving a variable name
you can't use any other sign except the
underscore or the dollar sign
you can use these two signs only you
can't use any other sign
you can't use a number in the starting
apart from that let's suppose you want
to give it a name as 9be you can't do
that in javascript javascript won't
allow you this if you try to save it it
will throw you an error invalid or
unexpected token so you can't do this in
javascript there is no limit for the
length of the variable name but you
can't use reserved keywords in a
variable name like let's try to create a
variable with name as class class is a
reserved keyword in javascript
we'll save it
and see here it throws an error
unexpected token class
but
you can use a class with capital c
let's save it and here it will work fine
why it works because javascript
variables are case sensitive if we try
to create a variable with same name
let's see we try to create a variable
with where girl and another variable
will be where girl with capital g this
time javascript will treat these two
variables differently these two are
different variables for javascript as
javascript is case sensitive when it
comes to variables
let's declare a few more variables let's
remove it we'll declare a few more
variables let's comment this part as
well
it will declare a few more variables
suppose we declare a variable with
keyword where and we'll name this
variable as bike name where
bike name
and press enter if we leave this
variable without assigning it any value
the by default value will be undefined
let's try to print the value of this
variable
right we will try to print the value of
byte name
save it here you can see the value it
shows is undefined so the by default
value of a variable if you do not assign
it any value will be undefined
let's try to give it a value let's
suppose we
try to give bike name
we use equals to operator to assign it a
value to assign let's suppose we'll
assign it
yamaha
semicolon and press ctrl plus s to save
this and here you can see the output as
yamaha
you can also assign a value to the
variable during declaration as we have
done in the previous examples here we
have assigned the variables value at the
time of declaration only let's move on
to let and const
so we will discuss let and cons but
first we will compare let with where let
is also used to declare a variable just
like where is used but there is a
limitation to use light
let is not accessible outside the block
in which it is declared
so we will use let here only let bike
name equals and we will change this
value as well we will change it to hero
let's say
save it and here you can see the output
as hero but
if we try to put this code inside a
block
let's suppose we put this code inside
this block a pair of curly braces
and we will again try to access
document.write we will try to access
bike name again from here from outside
the block we try to access this save it
and here you can see by name is not
defined it is an error in line 18. so
what's happening here basically you
can't access a let variable outside the
scope you can't access it from here but
it will work with where we try to
replace let with where and save it here
you can see it says hero and hero
because first it will interpret this
method and then it will interpret this
as well in case of where due to its
limited scope let variables are used
when there is limited use only like in
for loop or in while loop we will learn
these loop in future let will not allow
you to re-declare any variable let's
understand this with an example here is
the code as well we have declared where
bike name and we'll remove this
and first we'll try to do this with
where let's suppose where bike name
equals to
tvs control plus s it says hero and tvs
so the variable name the bike name is
same in both cases here and here as well
these are same but with where keyword
you can do that let will not allow you
to do this if we use let here in place
of
where we'll write let here as well and
we'll change the value as well we will
give it as
kawasaki
and
let's suppose suzuki here
save it
see bike name has already been declared
so that's what let won't allow you to do
you can repeat the same let variable in
different scope it won't create any
problem but it will not allow you to
re-declare any declared variable so
let's move on to const we use const when
there are values we don't want to change
or that will never change basically so
the keyword constant is little
misleading as it defines a constant
reference to a value not the constant
value we can't change the primitive
value but we can change the properties
of constant objects
let's write another piece of code for
const keyword
so let's declare a variable const
x
is equal to
comma y is equal to
7 let's say once
so here what we have done we declared a
variable x and a variable y with value
as 5 and 7 we declared this time with
const keyword and variable z which is x
plus y
we printed z on the browser and it shows
the value as 12 which is x plus y 7 plus
5 is equal to 12 now what we will do
const will let you do this but if you
try to update the value of x let's
suppose we try to
update the value of x as x equals to x
plus 10
we'll print
x this time
document.write
x let's save this it will throw an error
assignment to a constant variable in
line 24 so here you want to update the
value of x you can't do this with const
keyword you can do this with let and
where as well but you can't do this with
const
also const won't allow you to redeclare
any variable just like let so if you try
to use const x again
is equal to 10 save it
so here it says identifier x has already
been declared this thing you can do with
const the scope of const is the same as
let it can be used within the block
where it is declared data types is an
essential concept in every programming
language to work on any variable you
should know its type
it refers to the kind of data which is
being stored inside a variable
the type of variable is holding
basically
every programming language has its own
set of data types which is unique in its
own way
we discussed earlier that javascript is
a lightweight scripting language because
we don't need to specify any data type
in javascript after all all the
variables in javascript are loosely
packed or we can say javascript is a
dynamically typed scripting language we
shall discuss these properties later in
this video for now let me tell you about
different data types present in
javascript
so javascript data types are divided
into two categories primitive data types
and non-primitive data types primitive
data types are stored in stack whereas
non-primitive data types they are stored
in heap
i don't want you to go deep in these two
terms as if you are new to programming
so we'll leave it just keep one thing in
mind that primitive data types are base
data types whereas non-primitive data
types are objects or we can say they are
derived
primitive data types they are further
divided into five categories they are
divided as numbers strings boolean
undefined null non-primitive data types
or complex data types we can say on the
other hand they are divided into two
parts arrays and objects we'll have
separate videos on these topics for now
let's discuss primitive data types to
understand primitive data types much
better
let's declare a few variable here
let's say we declare where x and give it
the value as 16
we'll declare where y
and we'll give it value
hello wool we'll declare one more let's
say where
flag
and the value will be true
here we can talk about those properties
of javascript which i mentioned earlier
javascript variables are loosely packed
and javascript is a dynamically typed
scripting language these two points
refer to the same thing here you can see
we have defined three variables
x we have defined variable x we have
defined variable y and flag as well the
values for all three variables is
different from one another
see variable x is holding a value that
is 16 variable y
is holding a value hello world which is
a string so 16 is a number hello world
is a string
and variable flag is holding a value
that refers to a boolean value in place
of true we can also write false here
so
what's happening here here you can see
there is no data type if you are coming
from a c plus plus background or a java
background
this will be a little bit weird for you
guys because in c plus and java we used
to do it like we will define an integer
let let me show you
so how we will define integer in c plus
plus or what we'll say we'll use int x
equals to 5
or something like that we already had a
data type for string as well we have
carrying c plus plus but here in
javascript we have no data type we are
only using the where keyword that's what
we call as loosely typed
this line means that you don't have to
define the data type of the variable
what happens in javascript is whatever
the type of value you will pass to the
variable the data type will change
accordingly
so you don't need to worry about if you
are passing a number or if you are
passing in string
just relax just when you pass the value
to the variable it will be determined
automatically so these are the three
basic primitive data types present in
javascript
which are number
boolean value and
string so let's move on to the next one
which is undefined we'll define a
variable p
and we'll leave it as it is so this
variable p has an undefined data type it
means that any variable which is already
declared but has no value inside it it
has an undefined data type
i'll tell you a basic operator the type
of operator
we'll go through the operators in later
videos but just try to understand the
basic need and use it with me for now
this operator will help you know the
type of value a variable is holding see
let's use it here we have declared a
variable p
will check the type of p
so to use this operator you have to use
it with document dot right now
so we'll do document.write and we'll use
two brackets
and inside it will write
type of and whatever like if you want to
know the type of variable x let's
suppose we'll write here x
semicolon save it and you can see here
it says number this means that this
variable has a value which is a number
similarly we will check for all the
variables present here we'll check for
every variable we'll check for y will
check for flag and we'll check for p as
well let's copy this and
paste it three times and let's change
the value here
from x to y in this line
and from x to flag here
and here we'll change it to p
so we have done it we'll save it and see
here it says number first variable why
it says it's a string because you know
hello world is a string it's a sequence
of character
for
variable flag it says boolean so it's
defined as true or false and
for variable p it's written here
undefined
with this we are left with only one
primitive data type the null data type
there is a difference between a null
value and an undefined value undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
the absence of any value suppose you are
using null as the value for any variable
the type of operator will return this
variable as an object but if you are not
giving any value to this variable you
are leaving it after declaration the
type of operator will
return undefined here is an example for
this c
we'll declare one more variable here
we'll declare where
num let's name this variable num and we
will give it the value as null
we'll use document.write type of and we
will check with the help of type of
operator that what type of value the
variable num is holding so let's give
here
num
we are good to go press control plus s
and c
here it says it's an object
so a null value will always be shown as
an object
we'll talk about the complex types or
composite types in further videos we'll
have separate videos for each of these
types type conversion as the name
suggests conversion of value from one to
another in the previous video we
declared a few variables we declare
numbers strings and boolean as well in
javascript you can change the data type
of any variable from one to another you
can change a number to a string or a
string to a number
let's see an example of type conversion
let's declare a variable here
let's suppose we are using a variable
let's say
where num
equals 2 and the value will be 34 and
we'll
print it first
and we'll use type of operator to see
the data type of this variable
save it and see here it shows 34 and a
number i have already told you about the
use of console.log in this topic we'll
use console.log
just for a change you can use
document.write as well there's no
problem with any method you are using
let's move ahead and we'll declare a few
more variables
we'll declare a string and a boolean as
well let's suppose where str equals to
hello
and we'll print it as well let's copy it
from here and paste it here
and we'll declare one more variable
let's say where bool
equals to
true
let's print these three variables first
c the output is pretty simple we can see
the value and data types as well see 34
is a number hello is a string and true
is a boolean value
so
let's convert this number to a string
first this number 34 this is a number
here right and we'll convert this number
to a string so how to do it
that's pretty simple all you have to do
is write a word here let's write here
write string with a capital s
and put 34 inside a bracket so here we
are done with it save it and see here
you can see
34 which was a number first and now it's
changed to a string
that's how you can change the data type
of any variable let's try to change a
boolean value to a string now many of
you guys gets confused with boolean so
boolean is nothing
if something is true then set it to true
and if something is not true like if
it's false then set it to false see if
we talk about a real life example say if
you know how to drive create a variable
drive and set it to true and if you
don't know how to write set the variable
to false that's pretty simple that's
what boolean is let's change a boolean
variable to a string we have to follow
the same steps as we did for numbers
what we did we'll write here
string and put true inside brackets
we are done with it save it and check
the output here you can see the type
change from boolean to string like
string function we can also change a
string value to a number
so how to do it let's take a variable
let's say where
str1 will take let's say we are giving
it a numeric value let's say 8968
and what we'll do we'll write a console
log
and we'll print it basically
str1 and we'll
write here as well
save it and here you can see 8968 is a
string
so how to change this string to a number
that's also a simple task all you have
to do is write here number with capital
n and put this value inside brackets
save it and see here you can see 8968
changed to a number it was a string
earlier and now it's a number so if it's
a number now let's update this number
and we will see if we are adding
something to 8968 the value will change
or not let's update str1 what we'll do
we'll write str1 equals to str1
plus let's add a number say 2
so the output should be 8 8970 and the
type of operator will give the value as
number let's see what's the output now
save it and see
here you can see the output changed to
8970 but if you add an alphabet or a
character in the value then the output
will be different here we will copy this
whole code
and we'll paste it here
we'll change the value of str1 equals to
str2 and we'll use an alphabet along
with this number let's suppose it's
8968a
so a is in alphabet and
what we'll do we'll comment this line
and we'll go here and change the value
str1
here we are done with it save it here
you can see it says nan it means that
it's not a number it won't treat this
string as a number because it consists
of both numeric value as well as
character
now let's try to convert a boolean value
to a number in the case of a boolean
variable the scenario is a bit different
let's try this
let's declare a variable let's say we
are using where
bool2
and the value will be true
what we'll do we'll print the value here
here you can see true and the data type
of true is boolean so let's try to
change this boolean value to a number
that's pretty simple task write a number
and
put true inside brackets
save it and here you can see it says 1
in case of boolean variable
the value of true is 1 and the value of
false is 0. remember this guys keep this
thing in mind if you are changing a
boolean variable to a number then the
value of true will be changed to 1 and
the value of false will be changed to 0.
now let's have a look at parseint and
parse float as well after which i'll
tell you one more interesting function
let's move on to pass end first here
i'll declare a variable let's suppose
i'm declaring a variable let's say where
and we'll name this variable as number
the value will be
a string let's suppose it's 56
so we'll print it console.log
here you can see that the output is
showing 56 is a string so the data type
here is string because i have
used here single inverted comma so it
will take 56 as a string
now
let's suppose i want to parse this as an
integer or say i want to change it to a
number i can use parseint as well
apart from number if you want to use
number that's fine but apart from number
if you want to use parsnip you can use
it
let's see what happens if you use
percent use percent and put 56 inside a
bracket
save it and see here it changed the
string to a number 56 was a string
earlier right and now it's a number just
like parseint we have pass float as well
parsload will do the same thing but what
if you are using a decimal number here
let's see if you are using
56.343
save it
what percent will do it will give you
let's change 56 first
let's suppose we are using 65 now save
it and see
percent will give you the value as 65
only it won't show you the value the
decimal value
but if you are using here number or pass
float it will give you the whole numeric
value let's see what happens if you use
number here
number and save it here you can see the
value is 65.343
like number if you are using here pass
float
let's use parse float here
and we'll change the value here as well
let's suppose it's 72.543
save it and see here it will give you
the whole numeric value of the variable
i hope this is clear for you guys
now there is one more function you can
use in numbers which is dot to fixed
so this function has by default zero
value let's suppose i am using here we
have to use it here only
let's see what happens if i'm using
number dot
to fixed
so
inside bracket we are giving it a value
by default the value is zero let's
suppose we are giving it the value as 2
now save it and what will happen it will
give you the value as 72.54
similarly if you are using here some
other number let's suppose
7 you can see we have only three digits
after the decimal we have three digits
only that is five four and three what
happens if we run this program now let's
save it and see here it says five four
three zero zero zero zero so it will
show you the value up to 7 decimal
points
it doesn't matter if there are available
numbers after decimal point but it will
show you the value instead of 7 you can
also give here 30 let's save it and see
it says 6 6366 and so on hope this is
clear for you guys in any programming
language an operator is a symbol that
makes the computer understand that it
needs to do some specific task
like if we want to perform an addition
between two numbers let's say we want to
perform addition between four and five
so guys
if you see the plus sign here this is
known as the operator and the two terms
which are four and five these two
numbers
these are known as the operands
we have different operators for
different purposes like we have plus for
addition we have minus for subtraction
we have star or asterisk we can say for
multiplication
and many more other operators as well
so there are many more operators present
in almost every programming language
which is present out there like it
operators are present in java they are
present in c plus plus in c almost every
programming language out there has the
concept of operators it's essential for
you to know how
and where to use any operator despite of
the language you are working on one
needs to understand which operators are
available right so in this particular
video i'll take you through the basic
types of operator present in javascript
i'll let you know the types and we'll
learn about how to use them and of
course i'll take you through the
different categories of operators
present in javascript so in javascript
there are basically eight categories
into which operators are divided which
are we have arithmetic operators we have
assignment we have string we have
conditional we have logical bitwise
comparison and type of operator
we'll discuss the first three types in
this video that is we'll discuss the
arithmetic operators we'll discuss the
assignment and the string operators
rest we'll talk about in the following
video
first up here is the arithmetic operator
hope you all are aware of the term
arithmetic
right
so
arithmetic operators perform
mathematical calculations like it
performs addition subtraction
multiplication and division as well
so here are the few operators you can
see on your screen the plus operator
minus asterisk division we have modulus
we have increment we have decrement so
these are the basic arithmetic operator
we'll see each of these operator with an
example so let's move on to the
programming part first
so guys i want to mention one more thing
here i want all of you to make a
separate file for each topic we'll be
covering from now on like for operators
we'll create a separate file we'll
create a separate one for
control statements and other topics
we'll cover in future from today so i
want you to create a separate file
because you know in future if you want
to access these topics it will be easy
for you to access those files instead if
you are using a single file for all the
topics it will be
quite confusing so let's start with the
arithmetic operators first let's take
two variables we are in the javascript
file let's take two variables let's say
where
x equals to 6
and we'll take another variable let's
say where y equals to
4.
now we'll perform some arithmetic
operations on these two variables we
have already seen the arithmetic
operators present like we have plus
minus we have increment decrement we
have multiplication division so we'll go
through all of these right so let's
start with it here we are done with our
basic three operators which is addition
subtraction and multiplication i have
commented the division because i have
something to tell you about the division
so let's check the output here first
let's save it and see the output is
addition 10 subtraction 2 and
multiplication 24. for addition it added
the two numbers it's 6 plus 4 similarly
for subtraction and multiplication it is
6 minus 4 and it's 6 multiplied by 4.
for division i have left division
because i hope you guys know the
difference between division and the
modulus operator let's try to use the
modulus operator along with the division
so what we'll do we'll commend these
three and let's remove it from here and
what we'll do we'll
paste this here and we'll use the
modulus here so
now let's check the output what it says
for division and modulus
see
we have divided six by four
division it says it's 1.5
6 divided by 4 that is 1.5 it will show
the quotient here for modulus it's
saying 2 because
in modulus it gives you the remainder
and in
division it gives you the quotient as
the answer so keep this thing in mind
guys keep this in mind always take a
note of it so we are done with division
and modulus next up we have the
increment and the decrement operators
let me show them to you real quick so
what we'll do we'll declare another
variable let's say where z equals to 5
and
we'll use the increment operator here
we'll use again
document.write and here will let's say
we write increment how to use increment
operator for increment operator you have
to use
plus
plus whatever variable you have used so
we'll use plus plus
z and similarly we'll copy this
paste it here and here we'll use
minus minus for decrement
and change here as well
so let's see what happens
let me give
some space in between them so that you
won't get confused
let's save it and check the output here
increment is it says 6 and decrement it
is 5.
so you can see here the functioning of
decrement and increment operator the
increment operator will increase the
value of z by 1 and the decrement
operator will do the opposite of this it
will decrease the value by 1. so we are
done with the arithmetic operators next
up we have the assignment operators
assignment operators are used to assign
values to different javascript variables
let's see the types first and then we'll
see how to use them so we have these
assignment operators cf here we have
equals to plus equals to minus equals 2
and we have
multiplied equals 2 we have divide
equals 2 modulus equals 2
and a few more
so let's see each of them with example
maybe not each of them but we'll try to
cover almost every single operator out
there which is present in your screen so
let's move on and see let's move on to
the programming part so here we are guys
let's declare a few variables let's say
we are declaring a variable a
and we are giving it the value as 10
suppose
and we'll declare another one let's say
where b and give it the value
so for assignment operators what
assignment operator
mean
we have used here the equal to sign
right we have used a equals to 10. this
means whatever value present on the
right side of the operator like here it
is 10 it will be assigned to the
variable a
i hope you guys are getting this
keep this in mind
so we have the value 10 and we are
assigning this value to the variable a
it says let's try to check the output of
a let's try to print a on the screen
okay
document
see here you can see that the value of a
it says 10
and similarly the value of b is 5 so
let's do one more thing we'll assign the
value of a to b how to do this let's
change the value here only
let's suppose we are using the value of
where a as 13
okay and the value of where we will be
providing as let's say a
so
now let's try to print the value of b
here we'll change
will print the value of b only
let's save it and see the output see it
says the value of b is 13
because we have assigned b the value
present at variable a which is 13 that's
why it is showing the value of b as 13
this is what assignment operator is
let's try other assignment operators as
well
let's take another variable
so let's say where
even
equals to let's say 51
so the next operator we will be using is
let's update the value of a1 first so
how to
do this let's say a1 equals to
no it's a 1 plus equals to nine
and
we'll print the value
let's check the output now
see it says the value of a1 is 60 here
we have given that a1 plus equals to 9
see a 1 plus equals to 9 is the same as
if you don't want to write here a 1 plus
equals to 9 you can also write it as a 1
equals to
a 1
plus 9
both of these lines are same both these
statements means the same they are
performing the same task
so a 1 equals to a 1 plus 9 is same as a
1 plus equals to 9
that's what i want you to understand
with assignment operators
similarly if you want to perform a 1
minus equals 2 you can do it as well
so let's say a 1 minus is equal to 5
and we'll copy this line from here paste
it here again and save it now let's see
the output here what it says some of you
guys may get confused that here it shows
the value of 6 is 69 of a1 so in the
first statement when we tried to print a
1 here
the initial value was 51 then this
statement was performed and the value
was updated to 60
then after that one more statement this
statement is also performed and the
value updated to 69 it's 51 plus 9 plus
9 and the value we have here is 69 now
what happens if we are using the minus
equals 2 operator what it will do it
will
decrease the value of a1 by 5 it means
that
a1 equals to a1 minus 5 the value of a1
is 69 and it will subtract 5 from 69 so
here it says the value of a1 is 64.
hope you guys are getting this so we
have so many operators we have so many
of them like let's try a few more
so we have multiply equals to we have
division equals to we have modulus
equals two so i'll write these and then
we'll see the output
so we are done with it let's check the
output here for a3 a4 and a5 you can see
for a3 we have used multiply equals to
for a4 we have used divide equals to and
for a5 we have used modulus equals 2.
let's check the output here
save it and see
it says the value of a3 50.
it here we have taken a3 s5 it's 10 into
5 because a3 equals to a3 into 5 so it's
10 into 5 it shows the value as 50.
similarly
here it says the value of a4 is 3.75
because we have used here 4. so instead
of 4 let's try to use 3 and save it see
here you can see it divides it and gives
you the quotient and the value of a4
divided by 3 is 5.
so
similarly for a5 it shows the value of
a5 is 6
because we have used the modulus
operator here and 20 divided by 7 we
have 6 as remainder
so
i hope you guys are pretty clear with
assignment operators now next up we have
string operators the plus operator which
we used as the arithmetic operators
earlier right it also operates as a
string operator so we can use it to
concatenate two strings that mean we can
add two strings as well in javascript it
is possible with the help of string
operator similarly we have plus equals
to operator for strings as well like we
have plus equal to for assignment it has
the same functioning for string as well
let's take the example for these two
operators let's move on to the
programming part so here you can see we
have two variables where str1 and where
str2 the value of where str1 is hello
and the value of where str2 is world so
what we'll do we will add str1 and str2
so let's check the output here save it
and see here you can see the output as
hello world
but there is no space between hello and
world keep this point in mind guys so if
you are adding two strings just like
this there will be no space between the
two string so if you want to add any
space between these two what you have to
do you have to mention it here
separately
and this this is a syntax if you want to
add space between your strings
so let's save it now and see here you
can see there is a space between hello
and world
so this is the use of plus operator in
strings so the next one we have plus
equals to let's take another string
let's take it as where str3 and we'll
give it the value as
welcome
so what we'll do
we'll use the plus equal to operator
here str3 plus equals to
let's say
to
simply code
and
what we'll do will print the value of
str3 here
so save it now
so here you can see the value of str3 if
we remove this this line
let's see what happens now
and we'll give it a space here
save it now
see here you can see it says hello world
for the first str1 plus str2 it says
hello world for str3 it says welcome to
simply code see here the space is
already given so it will show this in
the output but between welcome and 2 if
you want to add space you have to
do the same what you have done for str1
and str2 so let's do it here on as well
plus sign yes save it now and see here
you can see
it says welcome to simply code with
proper space now we will cover the rest
of the operators now we are left with
five more these are the first three
operators now we are left with
conditional operators logical operators
we have bitwise operator and we have
comparison and finally we have the type
of operator
so these are the five operators we are
going to cover today
before we start with the operators let
us first discuss associativity
talking about associativity
it refers to the direction in which the
entire expression is evaluated for
example if you have any expression let's
say you have a plus b
so the direction in which this
expression will be evaluated either it
will be from left to right or from right
to left so this is known as
associativity let's understand it with
the help of an example
so here you can see i have taken three
variables i have taken variable a
and i have assigned it value as 12 i
have taken variable b
and the value assigned to b is 8 and
finally i have a variable result which
stores the value of a plus b
lastly what i am doing is i am printing
out the result variable inside the h1
tag here you can see i have used the h1
tags
and
i have used the plus operator to
concatenate the strings right i have
concatenated these two strings along
with the result along with the answer of
result
so the plus operator here is doing two
different tasks right
here you can see it is performing the
addition of two numbers right and here
you can see it is used to concatenate
two strings so now let's talk about
associativity because i guess you guys
are clear with string operator till now
we have discussed them in the previous
video right
so let's talk about associativity now so
certain operators have right to left
associativity and certain operators have
left to right associativity
so when i say right to left
associativity in this case the value
present at the right side of the
operator see if you are using any
operator for example here you we have
used the assignment operator right we
have discussed the assignment operator
earlier so here you can see the value
present at the right hand side of the
operator will be assigned to the
variable which is present at the left
hand side of the operator so
it's going this way like first the
computer will check the for the value
present at the right it's going from
right towards the left
this is what we are known as right to
left associativity and assignment
operators like equals to this have right
to left associativity
let's add here one more variable let's
say we are adding a variable variable c
and we are giving it the value as
five and what we'll do will update
result as well let me first show you the
output of this particular program see
the output will be value of result is 20
and high there high there is
concatenated with the string value of
result is and 20 is the actual answer
the 20 is the value of result
so let's add one more variable here
let's say we are adding a variable c and
the value of c will be 5
what we will do now we will update
result as well here you can see i have
done a plus b plus c
so
save it and here you can see the value
updated
to 25 the value of result is updated
right
so the plus operator has associativity
from left to right till now we have
talked about right to left as for
assignment operators but for plus
operators the associativity is from left
to right it means it will first perform
a plus b
and then the value of c will be added to
that of a plus b first it will perform
12 plus 8 and then finally it will add 5
to that value so it will be 20 plus 5
and that's why the output here is 25 we
know that javascript is a loosely typed
programming language right
which means that we don't have to
specify data types every time
like we are using if we are using any
data type we don't need to specify it
every time like let's do one thing let's
add a string here so what we'll do we'll
add a string let's suppose i'm adding
hello
so practically the answer would be hello
plus
25 or hello 25 it should be the answer
but let's check the output now save it
and here you can see the output is hello
one two eight five what happened here is
the associativity of the plus operator
is from left to right we know this so it
will start from the left and it will see
that okay the first thing to add is a
string so it will assume that everything
ahead of this will be a string that's
why we have the output as
hello
12 8 and 5 so 12 8 and 5 all are acting
as string here
let me clear this one for you with a
little bit of modification now what
we'll do
we'll
remove this string from here and we'll
add it somewhere else let's say we are
adding it here
so
let's add one more variable to make it
more clear let's say we are using
variable d and the value will be 10
and what we will do we will perform a
plus b before the string and then we
will perform c plus d
right so here you can see when you save
it
it says 20 hello 510 so when it reached
out the first variable it finds out that
the first variable is a number so it
added the first two numbers right it
added 12 and 8 the answer is 20 then it
came across this string hello and then
finally it assumed that everything ahead
of this will be a string so that's the
output 20 is the addition of a plus b
and then the string hello and finally we
have the value of c and d as string so
we have the value 5 and 10 not 15 right
i hope you guys get this
so
let's move on to conditional operators
the conditional operators assign a value
to a variable based on a certain
condition like it contains a condition
and you know for every condition like
there exists only two possibilities
either it can be true or it can be false
there is nothing else you can do with a
conditional operator so it works the
same as if else statements which we'll
cover in further videos the only
difference between if else and
conditional operators that it takes less
time or we can say its usage is pretty
easy
so here is the syntax for conditional
operators
so it seems pretty straightforward right
so here you can see we have a variable
name we have a condition depending upon
the condition we have two values
here is the example as well c
you can see we have a variable voter
next up we have a condition if h is less
than 18 so it will check for the
condition that if the value of age is
actually less than 18 let's suppose the
value of age is 15 so it will check if
15 is less than 18 it's true then it
will print 2 m or if the value of h
is greater than 18 then it will print
false or you can say it will print old
enough here
so let's move on to the programming part
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 30. what we'll do in variable y i
have given it a condition so it will
check for x which is 30 if 30 is greater
than or equal to 50
so if it's true if 30 is actually
greater than 50 then it will print true
else it will print false so we'll check
the output once let's save it and see
here you can see the output as false so
if we update the value of axial let's
suppose we are updating the value of x
let's suppose it's
60. save it now
and see the output has changed to true
because 60 is greater than 50 right
also if you want to write a message here
only you can do it write it here as
so we'll copy it from here we'll copy
document.write
and we'll paste it here
let's remove this document.right and we
what we'll do we'll
use this
bracket here
and if any message you want to write
like you want to write
value of
so
and now what we'll do we'll
save it
see it says value of true so
or you can write any other message here
as well you can write value of x is
greater than or you can write whatever
so if you want to update it like value
is
and here we will update true
with
greater
and here we will use
smaller
save it now see here it says value is
greater value of x is greater than y
so that's all for conditional operators
also one more thing conditional
operators has three different parts
right
and that's why it is also known as
ternary operator three different parts
as in it has a
condition like here it is it's it has a
condition and it has two values right it
has true or false so that's why it is
also known as ternary operator
next up we have the logical operators
so logical operators are used to
determine the logic between two
variables
or values we can say
we use logical operators to check
whether multiple conditions are true or
false
here on your screen you can see the
three different types of logical
operators present in javascript along
with the syntax and example
so the end or not are the three
operators present in javascript
the end operator here you can see
it it is holding two values right it
it has x less than 10 and y greater than
so the end operator will return true
only if both the conditions are true
like x has to be less than 10 and y has
to be
greater than 1 so here you can see we
have taken x equals to 7 and y equals to
4 so both the conditions are satisfying
here so that's why
the output of the and operator will be
true
for our operator the case is a bit
different so if any one of these two
conditions like we have two conditions
if any one of these two is true then the
output will be true and if both are
false then only the output will be false
the north operator on the other hand
will check if x is equals to y if the
value x is holding is equals to that of
y
if the value is not equal then it will
return true
i hope you are getting this that's a
little bit
confusing but if the value x and y
holding
if they are not equal then it will
return true if they are equal then it
will return false
right
we will understand the programming
concept of logical operators in further
videos when we learn about control
statements we primarily use logical
operators with the if statement through
which we'll come across in the following
video in the next video we will go
through the control statements so we'll
understand the programming part of
logical operator there only
next up we have the comparison operators
so comparison operators are similar to
logical operators in some way
they are also used to check for true and
false as the name suggests we use
comparison operator to compare two
values or we can say to compare two
variables using different operators
so here you can see on your screen
these are the different types of
comparison operators present in
javascript we have equals 2 we have not
equals 2 we have equal value and data
type we have greater than less than
and we have a few more so
i hope you guys must remember from the
previous video that a single equals 2
operator is an assignment operator so if
we are using a single equals 2 then it
will be considered as an assignment
operator for comparison we have to use
double equal to keep this thing in mind
whenever you are using any operator in
javascript or especially the equals two
operator so if you want to compare two
values you have to use double equals two
because single equals two is used to
assign values this is an assignment
operator so let's move on to the
programming part now
so guys here you can see i have taken a
variable x and the value assigned to x
is 10.
this code seems a little bit longer to
you but that's a simple piece of code
like i have used almost every comparison
operator we came across in the previous
slide i have used each one of them and i
have used the document.write after every
comparison operator to put some spaces
in between so that you guys don't
confuse between them
so let's check the output now see as you
can see i have used the double equals to
the triple equals to i have used x not
equals to it so let's check the output
save it and see here it says false false
true true true false true false so for x
equals to equals to it it compared the
value 10 with 8
and 10 and 8 are not equals to so the
output will be false as similar for 10
and we have used the triple equals 2
operator which means equal value and
data type so
both 10 and 8 have equal data type they
both have the same data type that is
number but the values are different so
it will print false
for x naught equals to it it says 10 is
not equals to it yeah 10 is not equals
to it actually so it will print true
similarly for x
naught equals to equals to it it will
check that
both the values are not equal but the
data types are equal right so it will
print true for this as well
for x greater than 8 yeah 10 is greater
than 8 so it will print true
similarly for it will check for x
smaller than 8 and it will check for x
greater than equals to it and also for x
less than equals to it
so
by now you have understood how
comparison operators work so comparison
operators are the easiest to use in
programming
and that's all for comparison operators
let's move on to the next one we have
the next type of operator we have is the
type of operator you guys have an idea
about the type of operators right as we
have discussed it earlier in case you
haven't watched the previous videos let
me give you a brief introduction about
this type of operator
so the type of operator is used to
provide you with the type of whatever
value you
put to the right of it like
if you are using any data type and you
want to know about the data type of a
particular variable let's say
so you can use the type of operator it
will tell you the actual data type of
any variable so
in javascript as we have discussed
earlier in the video where we have
particularly discussed about the data
types so there are five different types
of primitive data types right we have
the numbers we have strings we have
boolean we have null and undefined
so let's try to use type of operator
so here you can see i have used four
different variables which are i've used
variable x
variable y
and variable flag and variable p so the
values are different the x is holding 17
y is holding hey there and flag has the
value as false and i have defined p but
i have not assigned it any value till
now
so what i'll do i have used the type of
operator to find out the type of every
variable like here i have used it for x
for y for flag and for p
let's
check the output now
save it and see it says number string
boolean and undefined see here we have
given x the value as 17
so 17 is a number then it says it is a
number
for hey there it says it is a string for
false it says it is a boolean value like
in boolean value we have only two values
like false and true
so for variable p it says undefined
you know there is a difference between
undefined and null data types undefined
means lack of value whereas null means
this absence of value that there is no
value at all
so suppose you are using null as the
value for any variable right the type of
operator will return
object but if you are not giving any
value to any variable like you are using
the variable as it is like here we have
not given it any value so if you are
doing this the type of operator will
return undefined so let's take an
example of
null as well
let's declare another variable let's say
where abc
and we'll give it the value as
null
so and finally what we'll do we'll
use type of operator
save it and see here it says the type of
variable abc is an object
so remember this thing guys
and now we are done with almost seven
operators we had and we are left with
one operator only
so let's move on to our last operator
which is the bitwise operator this
operator doesn't have that much of
practical usage in the real world they
are not definitely useless but this is
something like we are not going to use
on a daily basis so in computers
if you know the numbers are stored in
binary format
bitwise operators work on 32-bit numbers
and we have decimal numbers like we
understand decimal numbers computer
works on binary numbers right so when
bitwise operators are used any operand
present in the operation
is first converted to a binary number
and then converted back to a javascript
number
so
here you can see on your screen
we have four different
bitwise operators we have the and
operator we have or we have not and we
have
zor or we can say exclusive or
the result and the answers are also here
it's pretty simple see
we have used the and operator before as
well while we were in logical operators
but the syntax was different and
here you can see we have a single
ampersand sign to use bitwise and
operator
so here you can see
how the decimal number first changes to
a binary number suppose we have x as 5
here you can see x is first changed to a
binary number this is the binary
equivalent of 5 and 1 is also changed to
a binary number and finally the result
whatever result we get it is changed to
a decimal number so that's how bitwise
operators work
let's take an example of bitwise
operators
so here you can see i have taken two
variables i have taken variable x and
the value of variable x is 5 and another
variable is y and the value of y is 1
and then i have used
all the four bitwise operators like i
have used x and y i have used x or y
i have used not x and i have used the
xor operator between x and y so let's
check the output now
here you can see if we talk about the
output
see here it says 1 5 minus 6 and 4 so
for x and y see
the value of x is 0 1 0 1 and for end
operators it will return one if both the
values are one if any one of the two
values are zero then it will return zero
so what it will return here it will
return zero for zero zero for one zero
it will also return zero similarly for
zero zero it will also return zero and
for one month it will return one
which is the binary equivalent of one so
the answer here is one
for x or y it will return one if any one
of the two values are one
see if both are zero it will return zero
if any one of the two values is one it
will return one
it will return zero again and finally it
has two ones so it will return one
and zero one zero one is the binary
equivalent of five that's why the output
here is five
for not operator it works a little bit
different it gives you the output which
is same as minus x minus 1 so minus x
minus 1 will be
see minus x minus 1 will be minus 5
minus 1 which is minus 6 so this is a
bit different here the not operator here
is a bit different
for
xor operator or we can say exclusive or
it will return 4
why it will return 4 it will return 1
when
any one of the two values is one if both
are one then also it will return false
it will return one only in one condition
if any one of the two values is one then
only it will return one that's why the
output here
the output here will be 0 1 0 0 that's
why it's written as 4 which is the
binary equivalent of 0 1 0 0.
so let's take a look at control
statements with the help of an example
let's suppose we have a piece of code
that has n number of statements here
let's say we have this code and so the
conventional workflow will be it will
first execute the first statement then
second then third and so on till
statement n right so this is the basic
flow right from statement one till
statement n and it will execute each
statement in between
however in real world the scenario is
different like we don't write the code
in same menu every time
for example let's suppose
you are in line 5
and you want to print this line 10 times
so what should you do
you can write this line 10 times or
you can copy paste it right okay let's
forget about 10 times let's suppose you
have to
use this
code or we can say let's suppose you
have to print this statement 100 times
doing this like copy pasting it for 100
times or writing this statement 400
times that's useless and unnecessary
right so that's where control statements
comes into picture
we'll discuss them in a while let's
assume another situation
this time you want to make a choice
based on certain conditions you can use
conditional operators but then it has
limitations right to tackle this problem
we have control statements in javascript
so these are the very basic reasons why
we need control statements for
performing a certain activity
like if we want to perform a certain
activity n number of times or if you
want to make a certain decision making
kind of scenarios in your program that's
where we need control statements in
javascript
in javascript we have two different
types of control statements depending
upon what action we are performing so we
have the conditional control statements
and we have the iterative or we can say
looping control statements
talking about conditional statements as
the name suggests we use conditional
statements when we have to make
decisions based on conditions when we
have two choices or when we can say when
we have two different conditions and we
want to make choices accordingly so
that's why we use conditional statements
we have two different types of
conditional statements the if else
statements and the switch case
talking about the iterative statements
as the name suggests if you want to
perform any action more than once or
maybe n number of times instead of
writing them again and again
we use loops so loops are basically
statements
we use loops to perform any activity n
number of times with specific conditions
so in javascript we have four different
type of loops we have for loop while
loop do while loop and foreign loop
so the for loop while loop and do while
loop you might have heard about them
earlier because they are also present in
other programming languages
but this foreign loop
this is a new type of loop present in
javascript we use foreign loop with
objects we'll go through objects in
upcoming videos and of course we'll be
looking at each of these control
statements in detail
will have a particular video for each of
these topic
now let me introduce to you the break
and the continue statement
they are not the types of control
statements but they do assist in other
control statements
the break is used to exit a switch
statement or loop like when used in a
loop
it breaks the loop and continues
executing the code after it
and
on the other hand the continue statement
breaks a single iteration when used in a
loop when we use continuous statement in
a loop it breaks a single iteration and
it breaks the iteration only if the
specified condition occurs and then it
will continue with the next titration in
the loop so the if else conditional
statement is used whenever we work with
condition
it can be either a single condition or
maybe more than one condition or
multiple conditions we can work with
so let's try to write a basic
program with a single condition
so then we'll
move on to multiple conditions using the
else if statement so we'll create a new
file today so i hope you guys know the
importance of creating a separate file
for every topic you know it will be easy
for you to work or to find out that
separate file later if you want to
revise that topic
so here is the program where we have
taken a variable x and the value of x is
10 so what we are doing in this program
is we are checking if the value the
variable x is holding that is the value
and if the value is less than
10 or if the value is
greater than 10 so we have only two
conditions either the value can be less
than 10 or the value can be greater than
10 or equals to 10 as
so here in this program what we'll do
will
first we'll update this value as 8 so
the variable x is holding the value 8
so to check the output let's save it and
here you can see it says the value of x
is less than 10 of course the value 8 is
always less than 10 right so
for 8 that's fine it will say the value
is less than 10 and similarly if we do
the same for let's say 11 save it now
and see it says the value of x is
greater than 10
so that's quite simple right but what if
we are giving the value as 10
we know 10 is equals to 10 so save it
now and see here you can see
it says the value of x is greater than
10.
this is happening because what we did we
as we told the interpreter to check the
value if the value of x is less than 10.
we didn't mention that if what to do if
the value is equals to 10 so it will
check for only x is less than 10 not for
equals to 10 or greater than 10 so here
what it is doing it is checking if the
value is less than 10 so that it says
okay let's print this statement if the
value is less than 10 or
if the value is not less than 10 or if
the value is equals to or greater than
10 it will print the value of x is
greater than 10.
to avoid this type of misunderstanding
we use an elsif statement so the concept
of elsif statement is the same as if
statement what we are doing we are using
multiple conditions right we are giving
it more than one condition so how to use
elsif it's quite easy
and the syntax is also similar to
the if statement the only difference is
that it contains an else before if so
it's an elsif so what we are doing is
we are giving it a condition that else
if x equals to 10.
so now what it will do it will check for
two conditions that if the value x is
holding is less than 10 or equals to 10
and what we'll do will update it is
let's check the output now
save and see here it says the value of x
is equals to 10 right so i hope you guys
are getting this
the execution flow for this program will
be like it will check for the first
condition if x is less than 10 if yes it
will print the value of x is less than
10. if no it will move on the to the
following condition like under the else
if statement it finds a condition that
if x is equals to 10 it will check for
it if yes if x is equals to 10 then it
will print the value of x is equals to
or if not then otherwise it will move to
else statement and print the value of x
is greater than 10. we don't need to
specify any particular condition for
this
you know because we have already
specified the two conditions that
if x is less than 10 or if x is equals
to 10 now we'll take a look at some
basic programs other than this one we'll
take a look at a few more basic programs
so here is the another program
what we are doing here is we are taking
a variable x and the value of x is 5
so what we are doing is we are checking
if the number is an even number or an
odd number thing you have to keep in
mind is the logic to find whether a
number is even or an odd number so to
check
whether a number is even you what we do
will divide that number with 2 right but
basically we want is we want
the remainder as 0 when we use the
modulus operator so what we'll do here
we have written x mod 2 equals to equals
to 0. so if the remainder is 0
then the number will be an even number
because it is divisible by 2. else it
will be an odd number so that's quite
simple right let's save it and check the
output for 5 it says odd number yeah 5
is of course an odd number right so
that's for even and ordinal
so here we are with another program
here it says we have a variable y and
the value of y is
let's say
and what we are doing here is we are
checking if a number is positive or
negative or 0
so we have 3 different conditions either
number can be positive or it can be a
negative number any number greater than
0 is a positive number right and any
number less than 0 is a negative number
and the third one is
a number 0 it's neither positive nor
negative
so let's check for the number 8 save it
and see here you can see it is a
positive number let's see for
minus 2 save it now it says a negative
number for 0 it will say 0
so these two programs are quite simple
guys right the conditions are pretty
simple we use
modulus operator we used greater than or
less than sign and
that's quite easy to use right so let's
move on to the next program which is a
bit tricky than these two
so what we'll do in our next program is
we'll check if a number is positive or
negative
and at the same time we'll check for
even and odd also
if we are giving any number as input
like let's suppose we are using 5 we'll
check if the number is positive or
negative and odd or even so we'll do
this simultaneously let's move on to
this program so there are two ways to
check whether the number is
positive or negative and
order even so the two methods we will
discuss them one by one the first one
here is
to use nested if and another one is when
we use logical operators along with the
if else if statement
so this one here you can see right in
front of your screen is
the
nested if method so here you can see we
have used the if statement we have given
one more condition inside another if
statement so first it will check whether
a number is positive or not for x
greater than 0 it will check if the
number x is greater than 0 then if yes
if it will find it that yes this number
is greater than 0 then it will move on
to the
nested if and it will check for odd or
even
for odd number and even number it will
check if it finds that the number is
even it will print that the number
is positive and even
if the number is not even it will print
the number is positive and odd so
here you can see the difference what the
interpreter is doing is it will check
for the number as positive and if the
number is positive then it will move on
to the nested if and check for the even
or odd so if it finds that the number is
even it will print positive and even
otherwise it will print positive and odd
then it will move on to the next
condition which is for negative number
if x is less than 0 then it will again
move to the nested if and it will check
for even and odd
so if it finds that the number is even
it will print negative and even
otherwise it will print negative and odd
and the last condition is for the number
let's
try to find out the output of this and
what we'll do we'll update the value of
x as
8.
so save it now here it says then
positive and even so 8 is a positive
number and even as well
let's update the value of x as minus
save it now it says negative and odd
number minus 5 is a negative odd number
right so that's how it will check for
positive
or negative and odd or even so we are
doing both the things simultaneously in
a program
we have an alternate method as well here
you can see on your screen we have
written a program and here we have taken
a variable x the functioning of both the
programs is same
both of these program will check for
positive or negative and
order even
so here you can see i have taken a
variable x let's say the value of x is
it will check for
x greater than 0 and x
mod 2 is equals to equals to 0. so we
have 4 different conditions right
a number is
greater than zero that means a number is
positive and even a number is positive
end odd a number is negative and even a
number is negative and odd and the final
one is a number is zero
okay we have five conditions and we have
to specify these four conditions
so here we you can see we are using the
logical and operator this means it will
print this statement let's suppose for
this statement it will print this only
if both the conditions are true
right if the number if the value x is
holding is both greater than 0 and an
even number
so if you try to
find out the output now save it and see
here it says number is positive and odd
so the number 7 is greater than 0
but the number 7 is not an even number
that's why this line is not there on the
browser it will print this line because
the number is
positive and odd the switch case is
another conditional control statement
and just like the if else control
statement there is a difference between
the usage of if else and switch case
statement
now both if else and switch case works
with conditions and we have to choose
when to use switch case
over if else
switch case is generally preferred over
the if else when there is n number of
test cases present or we can say when we
are working with a lot of conditions
let's say we are working on a program
and you ask the user
for
an input between 50 and 100 a numeric
input basically
and in the output we have to print the
textual form of that number suppose if
the user enters 75 right the output will
be like this
so what we are doing we we are taking a
number from the user as an input and we
are printing the textual form of that
number right
so we can use the if else
or we can say elsif control statement
but the program will be so lengthy and
not so clean
also switch case is much more efficient
than if else when it comes to execution
time like if we have n number of
conditions then using switch case is a
better option
will get to know why in a bit so let's
move on to the programming part and
today
we'll write a program where we have to
find the month in a year by accepting
its number so we have 12 months in a
year for example if we enter 4 then the
output will be april and if we enter 8
then the output will be august because
august is the 8th month of the year
right so i hope you guys are clear with
the question of course we can do this
program with the help of if else
statement but we discussed earlier that
using if else in such cases is not
efficient right we can use switch case
in this scenario
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and
you can
give any value to this variable from 1
to 12 you can provide it with any
initial value
so let's create a variable first let's
say we are creating a variable where
month and
the value we are providing it one as the
hardcore initial value for simplicity
again we are not taking the input from
the user or from the browser to do so we
have to first go through the dom
manipulations and we'll go through it in
later videos so let's start with the
switch case now
the syntax for switch case is quite
simple just write down
switch and
pass the variable month
so we have to check in this round
bracket for the variable month because
you know any value you are providing to
month the switch will check the program
accordingly so for now we have taken the
value as 1 for month we can take any
value like we can take 3 we can take 11
12 or any value other than 1 to 12 as
well so whatever value you are providing
to the variable you can provide the
variable to the switch statement right
so
next up we have an open and curly braces
for the body of the switch case we have
to test for 12 different conditions
inside this
starting from 1 to 12 right so the
syntax goes like this you have to write
case
and then the value
month variable might hold like 1 2 3 and
so on followed by a colon right so we
have to write the value 1 and
a colon not a semicolon but a colon keep
this thing in mind guys
and below that we are going to write
what we want when the value is one like
what the output we want when the value
is one so we have to write
document
dot write
and
whatever you want as the output like for
one the first month is january so we are
writing here
january
and a semicolon
so if the value of the month is one you
will get the output as january save it
and here you can see the output is
january
let me increase the font size for this
as well
so here you can see the output is
january right next we'll use a break
statement
if you guys remember we discussed the
break statement in the control
statements video right the break
statement is not actually a type of
control statement but it assists other
control statements or we can say it
helps us manage the control statements
right what this statement does is
once we are done with our output we get
our output right once we are done with
case 1 we get our output as january this
break statement helps us to come out of
the switch case
so to understand this much better let's
write here one more case
so let's say we are
writing here one more case as
case 2
and the output will be document
dot write
the second month is february right
and
february i can write so
will include one break here like will
come in the first case and include a
break statement so here's how you can
write a break statement how you can
include a break statement in your code
so let's check the output now so for now
it says january
so if we don't include this break
statement here when the interpreter will
execute this code
and it will see that the case is one
right so it will print january
but
it will print other statements as well
so for example if we remove this break
statement and save it now see you can
see here the output as january and
february january and february both are
getting printed on the output so we need
a break statement to break it here
see the value is 1 and if we include
break statement here
the moment the interpreter finds the
answer the correct answer as january it
will come out of the switch case
so i hope you guys are getting this
similarly will write all the cases for
all the months let me show you all the
cases
so here you can see on your screen that
we have 12 different cases from 1 to 12
one for each month depending on the
value the variable month is holding
right
the output will be june if the value is
6 and if we say 10 the output will be
october and so on and so forth
now
the question here is what if we try to
write a random value for the variable
month
by random value we mean that
if we try to write any value other than
these 12 values from 1 to 12 if
we leave these values then if we try to
write another value like if we write
here 13
so what will be the output now let's
save it and see
there's no output and there might be no
error for this as well so if you try to
check for an error go to inspect and
check out
see there is no error right so in that
case we have one more case like we have
default case
so let me show you how to include
default in your program what you have to
do is write here
default
with a colon and write
document
dot right and
let's suppose we are writing here
wrong input
what is happening is let's try to run
this program first
press ctrl s and now you can see it says
raw input for value 13.
so what is happening is the switch case
will first check these 12 cases and any
value other than 1 to 12 will get the
output as wrong input it works the same
as the else statement right in else
statement we don't need to specify any
particular condition any condition other
than the if condition or else if
condition will fall inside the else
statement it's not necessary to add
default in your program it's just if you
want to give the user a prompt that he
has entered a wrong value
so
you must include this default case in
your program every time while using
switchgear because it's quite useful you
know
okay so this is the complete program to
find out
the month by accepting its number
if you try
six
and save it now it will say june if we
try 10 save it it will say october if we
try 12 save it it will say december so i
hope this is clear to you guys
next up let's discuss about switch case
in detail because the switch case in
javascript works differently from other
languages like switch case is also
present in c plus plus and java but in
javascript it is a bit different so in
javascript switch case can accept
numbers it can accept strings and
boolean values as well
now let's have a look at how the switch
case works with string values
so here is an example of string values
you can see the value variable month is
holding is june right and you can use
this string in case as well so here you
have to
give the case as a string value right
because we are using switch case
statement with
strings so the first case here is when
the value will be june the output should
be sixth month and when the value is
july the output will be seventh month so
let's check it out if this is working or
not let's save this program and see for
june it says sixth month and similarly
we can check it for july as well let's
check for july
save it and see it says seventh month
you can include the default case as well
if you want to it will be similar like
there is no difference for default case
let me show you how
we'll write here wrong input
and save it and now let's try to change
the value here let's say we are using
may
save it and see it says wrong input but
if we use a numerical value here let's
try to use two save it now it says wrong
input for 2 as well it will give you the
output when the value is either june or
july
so any other value you try to use here
it will give the output as wrong input
in the same way it works for boolean
values as well let me show you how it
works for boolean values
so what you have to do instead of 2 you
have to give here a boolean value let's
suppose you are writing here true
and for true you have to change the case
as well for true
you have to change the output as
let's say for true it the output will be
one
okay and similarly for false
the output should be
zero
and the output should be wrong input for
any other case right so save it now and
see here for true it says one the output
you can see here is one
and if you try to do the same for false
like let's write here false
and now try to check the output see here
it says
zero
you can see the output is correct right
so we will discuss
our first iterative control statement
that is the for loop in javascript
so iterative statements or looping
statements we can say are used when we
want to perform an activity multiple
times or n number of times so we don't
have to copy paste that code every time
but we can use iterative statements
using iterative statements will make our
code clean and definitely more efficient
so we have four different types of
iterative control statements right we
discussed it in the previous video let's
move on to for loop which is a first
iterative control statement and we'll
move on to the programming part directly
so before we start one thing to keep in
mind guys is that
we use for loop when we are clear with
the number of iterations in advance
so let's start with our first program in
this program we will print the
multiplication table of 10 from 10 into
1 to 10 into 10
let's start with coding
first we write the for keyword and then
we have
three different parts we have the
initialization
which is separated by a semicolon next
up we have the condition
and finally
we have the increment or decrement
so this is the syntax for for loop
next up we have the open and the closed
curly braces for the body of for loop
we'll change these three values
as these are not the actual values right
or parameters for these three different
parts of the loop are going to be
different
so let me comment this one
so we'll what we'll do we'll leave it
here only we'll change it from here so
in the initialization part what we are
going to do is we'll create a variable
let's say we are creating a variable
where a and the value of and the initial
value of a will be 1.
this initialization happens only one
time when the for loop begins we have to
be careful about the condition we are
going to use
because sometimes what happens is the
loop runs forever because of a wrong
condition which will ultimately crash
our program
so in the condition what we have to do
is we have to give a value as in for how
long a for loop should execute here in
this case
we want to print the table of 10 right
we want to have 10 iterations
so what it will do it will start from a
equals to 1 and it will go till this
final condition so let's suppose we are
writing here a less than equals to 10
it will start from
a equals to 1 and it will go till a less
than or equals to 10 and next up we will
use the increment operator we want to
increment the value of a by 1 every time
right so we'll use increment operator a
plus plus or we can say a equals to a
plus 1 both are the same things right so
here the condition will be like this for
variable a equals to 1 a less than
equals to 10 and a plus plus
so here you can see the loop will
execute from a equals to 1 till a equals
to 10 and the value will be increased by
1 every time
because
we have used the increment operator
right next up the body of for loop will
go like so what we want to print here we
want to print the
table of 10 right so we'll use document
dot write and inside document.write
we'll use the h1 tag
so what we want to do is we want to
print the table of 10 right so
we'll multiply 10 by a
for every iteration the value of a will
be multiplied by 10 and then it will be
printed on the browser
so we'll close the h1 tag here
in the semicolon
so here you can see we have printed 10
into a let's save it and check the
output first and then we'll look at the
execution flow of this program
see here the multiplication table of 10
is printed on the browser you can see 10
20 30 40 so on and so forth till 100
so what is happening is firstly the for
loop is also known as the entry control
loop it means
that the condition is checked initially
the first time the for loop runs
we perform initialization only once so
here the value stored at variable a is 1
initially the value is 1 next up it will
check for a less than equals to 10 is a
which is 1 is 1 less than equals to 10
then true the control will be shifted to
document.write and it will print
10 into the value of a is 1 right so it
will print 10 here
next thing it will go for the increment
and the value of a will be changed to 2
from 1 1 plus 1 or we can say 1 equals
to 1 plus 1 right so it will be 2 now
next thing it will leave this now
because the initialization happens only
once now it will go for the condition
directly now it will check for is 2 less
than or equals to 10 if yes then again
the control will be shifted here and it
will print 10 into 2 because the value
of a is 2 now
and after that it it will print 20 here
and after that
the value of a will be increased to 3
because we have used a plus plus then it
will check for 3 is 3 less than 10 and
same thing will happen it will print 30
and so on and so forth till the value of
a is 10 now if the value of a is 10 it
will print 100 right and when the value
is incremented it will become 11.
so what will happen now it will check
for 11 less than equals to 10.
no we know that 11 is not less than
equal to 10 right then it comes out of
the loop and it will print nothing after
that so this is the basic working of the
for loop we'll go through one more
program wherein we'll print the odd
numbers
between 1 and 10.
so what are odd numbers odd numbers are
those numbers which are not divisible by
2 right
so we have the odd numbers as 1 3 5 7 9
and we want to print them so the
difference between each number is of 2
the 1 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 till 9 right
so what we have to do is we have to
write here a
plus equals to 2. we have to increase
the value of a by 2
and instead of writing here 10 into a
because this time we don't want to
print any multiplication table we want
to print a number only right so we'll
use a only
save it and check the output it says one
three five seven nine so these are the
odd numbers present between one and ten
keep one thing in mind that you have to
give the condition wisely every time
so next up we have the while loop like
the for loop while loop is also an entry
control loop which means that the
condition will be checked first so the
question here is how while loop is
different from the for loop if you guys
remember when we discussed that we must
know the exact number of iterations then
only we can use the for loop right so
the while loop is preferred when we are
not aware of the number of iterations or
we can say we don't know if the
condition will be true for a certain
number of times
we'll start with the programming part
now
and then we will discuss more about when
to use while loop over for loop
so let's start with the program in this
particular program we will print odd
numbers up to a specific number
let's say we want to print all the odd
numbers up to 50.
so we want to print all the odd numbers
from 1 till 50 right we came across the
same program in the previous video as
well but this time we will use the while
loop instead of for loop
so the syntax for the while loop is
relatively easy to use
the code goes like we start with the
while keyword
then
opening and closing round brackets and
finally the body of while loop in curly
braces
if you guys remember from the previous
video wherein we used the for loop we
had three different parts right we had
the initialization we had conditions and
the increment decrement part here we
have only one condition and until this
condition holds true the while loop will
be executed for example here we want to
print all the odd numbers from 1 to 50
right so we'll first initialize a
variable
let's initialize the variable first
let's say we have a variable x and the
value of x will be 1.
we used here 1 because
1 is the very first odd number right
after that inside the condition what we
want to do is we want to print the odd
numbers
up to 50.
so while the condition will be like
while
x
less than equals to 50
so the loop will go till x
is less than or equals to 50
or we can say x less than 15. that
depends on us if we want to check for 50
or not so the odd numbers will go like
1 and then we have 3 then we have 5 then
we have 7 and up to
50. so the last odd number will be 49 so
inside the while loop we will print the
value of x so here we will print the
value of x let's print it
document
dot right
and inside this we will print the value
of x inside the h1 tag
suppose we try to run this program now
it will go on an infinite loop and the
reason for this is we are not doing
anything to increment the value of x
just like in for loop if you remember we
had the initialization first we had the
initialization here as well
then we had the condition we have a
condition here as well and then finally
it has an increment or decrement part
right so here we don't have that same
increment or decrement part we have to
do it separately so we'll increment the
value of x here only so here we will
write x
plus equals to 2 or we can say it is
same as
x equals to x plus 2 you guys are aware
of it right so
the reason is simple because we want to
go from 1 to 3 to 5 and so on that's why
we use x plus equals to 2 we incremented
the value of x by 2.
save it here and let's check the output
so here you can see it says 1 3 5 7 9
and
so on and so forth till 49 so 49 is the
last odd number before 50 because we are
checking between 1 and 50 right so 49 is
the last
odd number
let me show you how the program goes
into an infinite loop
so for that what we have to do we will
comment this whole line here let's check
the output now save it and here you can
see
it is refreshing forever and this is
basically how a program in an infinite
loop looks like
the output of this program is the
program will ultimately crash so what we
have to do we have to open a new tab and
then again we have to run the program
with correct increment part so here you
can see you can wait for it to become
responsive or exit the page so here you
can see we have all the odd numbers from
up to 50 and the last one is 49
coming back to the difference between
the while loop and the for loop we did
the same program previously right using
the for loop so where to use
while loop
over for loop so consider a scenario
where we are taking input from the user
and the input from the user is why we
want to do something let's say we want
to print something on the screen or if
the input from the user is n we want the
process to be stopped we can give the
condition in the while loop which will
go like when the character y becomes n
the process will be stopped we'll go
through one such program once we are
done with the dom manipulation part
wherein we take the input from the user
let's move on to the do while loop in
javascript
in the previous videos we have already
discussed that both for loop and the
while loop are entry control loop that
means the conditions are checked first
right but the do-while loop is a bit
different or we can say it is an exit
control loop wherein the condition is
checked after the execution of the
loop's body thus an exit control loop
executes at least once even if the test
condition fails or we can say the
condition is wrong
the loop will execute once
using the do while loop is relatively
easy it seems like we are giving the
system a command to do something while
the condition is something so let's
start with the syntax now
the syntax goes like this we write the
keyword do and we have a pair of curly
braces for the body of the loop and
after that we have the while keyword and
here we will write the condition
make sure you are using the semicolon
after the while loop it's necessary
while using do while loop keep this
thing in mind
so we have two parts in the do-while
loop the do part and the while part or
we can say the condition part while part
is the part where we write the condition
so let's define a variable first let's
say we are using a variable we are using
a variable x and the value of x will be
5.
so here we have taken 5 as a random
value you can take 1 as well now inside
the condition part of the do while loop
this is the condition part where we are
using the while keyword so we'll give a
condition let's say we are using while x
greater than 5 it will check for the
condition that if the value of x is
greater than 5
or if the value of x is smaller than or
equal to 5 it will come out of the loop
in the do part we will write what we
want to do let's say we want to print a
single sentence here
we write document.write
and whatever sentence we want to write
let's say we are using
welcome to
simply code so here you might be
thinking that the condition is false but
the condition will be checked after the
first iteration in the do while loop so
no matter what the condition is the
first iteration will happen always
so if we try to save this program and
let's try to run this
here you can see the output is welcome
to simply code
a single line is printed
what is happening here is although the
condition we used was wrong but the
condition will be checked only after the
first iteration when the do-while loop
will perform this
particular statement when the
document.write will be performed after
that it will check for the condition if
x is greater than 5 or not
if we use here 6 instead of 5
let's try to write here 6 instead of 5
and if we run this program now it will
go into an infinite loop because we are
not performing the increment decrement
operator here right
as we have discussed in the previous
videos the importance of increment
decrement part
so we need to do it here after the
document.write part so what we'll do
here we'll write x minus minus today we
are using x minus minus and for the
other two loops we use the plus
increment operator right so the x minus
minus is the same as x equals to x minus
1 let's check the output now
save it here you can see the output is
still welcome to simply code the
execution flow of this program will be
like it will first perform the iteration
before checking the condition
and it will print here welcome to simply
code for the first time when the loop
will start executing it will first
perform this statement and it will write
here welcome to simply code
so then it will perform x minus minus
means the value of x is now 5 because we
are decrementing the value by 1
so when the value of x is 5 then it will
check for the condition if x is greater
than 5 or not so here we can see clearly
x is not greater than 5 because x equals
to 5 and it is equals to 5 right so it
will come out of the loop
let's make few changes in the code here
suppose
we use here 10 instead of 6 now and
let's print the value of x as well it
will be easy for you to understand so
we'll print here x
and we'll use a
space
so that it will be clear for you
we'll use here the brtech and now let's
try to run this program here you can see
the output goes from 10 to 6 and it
prints welcome to simply code every time
right if you guys are wondering where we
use the do while loop sometimes it may
happen that even though the condition is
false but we have to execute that
command we use the do while loop when we
want the code to output some sort of
menu to the user or to generate the menu
at least once we'll get to know about
the do while loop in future videos when
we create a program specifically for the
do while loop this video is just a
syntax demonstration
we'll go through the examples
of all the three loops present in
javascript so today we have three
different problems
for three separate loops right we'll go
through each of the problems and we'll
discuss the execution flow for each loop
will go through
so let's start this session with the
first problem statement so the first
problem statement goes like this so here
we have to write a program to check
whether a number is prime or not i hope
you guys are aware of what prime numbers
are right so a prime number is a
positive number that is only divisible
by 1 and itself for example
2 3 5 and we have 7 and 11 these are the
first few prime numbers right
if we take an example let's say we are
taking an example of 7 so 7 is a number
which is divisible by 1 and 7 only no
other number can divide 7 right so here
in this code we have to check whether up
number is prime or not so let me take
you through the code
so here is the code to check whether a
number is a prime number or not let me
take you through this first
so we have a variable number and the
value of variable number can be any
random value like any number you want to
check if the number is prime number or
not you can give that value to the
variable number
so here we have taken 83 next up we have
a variable is prime
whose value is a boolean value right it
can be true for a prime number or it can
be false for a non-prime number
so we have used comments in this program
to make it easier for you guys to
understand so here we have used the if
statement to check if the number is 1
because we know that 1 is neither a
prime number nor a composite number
right so we have to check if the user
enters the value 1 or if we are giving
the value 1 we have to check for it so
if user enters the value 1 it will print
this statement that 1 is neither prime
nor composite here in elsif we are
checking if the value of number is
greater than 1 or not so if the value of
number is greater than 1 the control
will be shifted to for loop present
inside the else if statement right here
you can see we have the for loop here
the control will be shifted to this for
loop so here you can see we have
initialized the variable i
and the initial value is set to 2
that's because any prime number is
divisible by 1 as well right so it won't
make any sense to include 1 here
we'll start from 2 and we'll check until
the value of i becomes half of the value
of number so if we take an example of 10
we'll check until 5 because you know any
number greater than 5 won't divide 10
right it's practically not possible so
we'll check for number by 2 or we can
say we'll check till 5 only and the
value will be increased by 1 every time
till now i hope you guys are aware of
how to use for loop and why we are using
for loop here we can do the same program
using while loop as well but to make it
more clear how to use for loop we are
doing this program with the help of for
loop so then we have the i plus plus or
we can say we have increased the value
of i by one after every iteration until
the value of i becomes
half of the number
so the condition number percent i equals
to equals to zero
so here is the main condition to check
if the number is divisible by
i or not so the execution will be like
if we are taking here a number 10 it
will start from 2 and it will check if
the remainder is 0 or not so if the
remainder is 0 then the value of s prime
will be changed to false and it will
come out of the loop
next it will check for the value of s
prime if the value of s prime is true or
not here you can see if the value of is
prime is true then it will print
n or we can say then it will print that
the number is a prime number else it
will print that
the number is not a prime number if the
value of s prime is false for example
when we took the example of
number as 10 so the value of s prime
will be changed to false because you
know 10 divides by 2 is equals to 0
or we can say the remainder will be zero
so the value of this prime will be
changed to false and for false it will
print number is not a prime number
so at last we will check if the number
is less than one if the number entered
by the user or any other number we have
taken like if we take here minus 5
so it will print the number is not a
prime number
because by the usual definition of
prime numbers
any negative number
cannot be a prime number that's a usual
definition right so we have to keep this
thing in mind and here in this else loop
we'll
print that if any negative number is
entered we'll make sure that the program
gives the output that the number is not
a prime number
so let's try to run this program and
check the output let's save this program
and
the output says 83 is a prime number as
83 is not divisible by any number except
1 and 83 for example if we take here any
number which is divisible by so let's
say we are taking 75 save it now and see
it says 75 is not a prime number okay
here's a spelling mistake it says 75 is
a not prime number so here we will
correct this
is
so we are done with it and save it now
now it says 75 is not a prime number s75
is divisible by numbers other than one
end itself right it is divisible by 3 it
is divisible by 5 15 and 25 as well all
these numbers divide 75 basically
so let's take a different value here
let's say we are taking
minus 7
let's change the value here as or we can
take it as minus 75 let's save it now
so it says the number is not a prime
number
or if we want to try for 1 as well let's
take it as 1
and let's check the output now so it
says 1 is neither prime nor composite
number because we have given here the
condition if number is equals to is
equals to 1 then it will print that 1 is
neither a prime nor a composite number
you can try this program with the help
of other loops as well
so let's move on to the second problem
statement but before that let me take
you through
the same program using the while loop so
here you can see we have used the while
loop for
the same instead of for loop here you
can see we have used while i
less than a
number by 2 and we have given the
increment condition here and we have
initialized the value of i
at
the start of the program so if we try to
run this program it will give us the
same output there will be no change in
the output so we can use while loop as
well so we'll use the while loop in
other program
let's move on to the second problem
statement so in this example we'll learn
to write a program in javascript to
check whether a number is an armstrong
number or not
so we'll do this with the help of while
loop let's have a look at how to
implement this program
before proceeding to the coding part
let's have a look at what is an
armstrong number so an armstrong number
of three digits is an integer such that
the sum of the cubes of its digits is
equal to the number itself
so for example 153 is an armstrong
number since
1 into 1 into 1 it means the cube of the
digit 1
plus the cube of 5 that is 5 into 5 into
5 which is equal to 125 and the cube of
3 which is three threes are nine and
nine threes are 27 so it will go like
plus 27 plus
1 so which is equal to 153 so an
armstrong number of three digits is an
integer such that the sum of the cubes
of its digits is equal to the number
itself so here we have the code for the
same this is the code to check whether
the number is an armstrong number or not
so here we have taken a variable and the
value is 153 the value of the variable
number is 153 right because we already
know that 153 is an armstrong number
there are few more numbers like 3 7 1 is
also an armstrong number
next up we have taken a variable sum and
the initial value of sum is
0 we have used the variable sum to store
the value of the cubes
and next up we have a temporary variable
so that we can break a three digit
number and we need
the number after all this all this
program all these loops and all will
need the number we'll need the original
number to compare it with the sum of the
cubes which will be hold in sum so but
we need to break the number as well
right so we need a temporary variable to
break it
here we use the while loop and the loop
will run until the value of variable
temp is greater than zero so the initial
value of temp will be one five three
here in this particular case the initial
value will be one five three and the
loop will run until the value of one
five three is greater than zero
next up we have a variable remainder
that stores the
last digits value as we are dividing 153
by 10.
so
the remainder here will be three so the
value saved at variable remainder will
be 3 for the first time then what will
happen with we are updating the value of
sum and the new value of sum will be
0 plus 3 into 3 into 3 so 3 3's are 9
and 9 3's are 27 so
the
updated value of sum will be 27 next up
we are
removing the last digit from the number
so
for example we have here 153 and if we
divide 153 by 10
the answer will be 15.3
that's why we are using here percent
because what percent will do it will
convert the float value into an integer
so if we try to perform a simple divide
in javascript like if we try to divide
153 by 10 it will give us 1 5.3 it will
give us a float value but we want an
integer value right so pass it will
change this value to the nearest integer
so 1 5.3 the nearest integer will be 1 5
so the new value of temp will be 1 5
then again this loop will be executed
and
for this time the variable reminder will
hold the value of 15
modulus 10 and the remainder will be 5
right
so the new value of remainder is 5 and
the value of sum is 27 plus 5 into 5
into 5 which is 27 plus 125 right so the
new value of sum will be 152
and then again it will go to the temp
and it will divide 15 by 10 and it will
change the value to an integer so 1.5
will be changed to 1 and next up the
final value of temp is 1 which is
greater than 0 right so it will divide
10 by 1 and the remainder will be 1
so next up it will add 152 plus 1 into 1
into 1 that is 153 right and then it
will divide 1 by 10
using the power sent but this time the
value will be 0 because there is no
remainder right
next up we'll compare the value of the
sum and the number variable so the sum
variable here it is holding the value as
153. we break this number into three
different parts then we took the cube of
these three number and added them so the
final value of the variable sum is 153
and the initial value of number or we
can say the value we gave to the
variable number is 153 so right it will
print here that 153 is an armstrong
number
or if we use any other number instead of
153 let's suppose we are using 121 so it
will print 121 is not an armstrong
number let's
check out the output once let's save it
and see the output here is 153 is an
armstrong number so if we change the
value of one five three to
one to one
so let's check the output now it says
one two one is not an armstrong number
why because if we take the cube of each
of the digit and we'll add them suppose
the answer here will be 10 because the
cube of 1 is 1 and the cube of 2 is 8
and the cube of the final one is 1 so 8
plus 1 plus 1 is equals to 10
so that's why 1 2 1 is not an arm strong
number
let's move on to our last problem
statement
where we'll use the do while loop to
find the factorial of a number
so here is the problem statement where
we'll have to write a program
to find the factorial of a number
so factorial of an integer is the
product of an integer and all the
integers below it or we can say before
it till 1 so if we take an example of 5
so the factorial of 5 will be
it will multiply each number before it
if we take 5 the factorial will be
into 4 into 3 into 2 into 1
or if we don't include 1 that's totally
fine
so this program is pretty simple as
compared to the previous two we did
so this is a small one too let me take
you through this so here we have the
program
and here we have three variables right
we have a variable i which is
initialized as 1 then we have a variable
n which is 5 and then we have a
variable f whose value is 1 f is for
factorial and n is for number we want to
check the factorial of and i is for
checking the condition
so here what we will do we'll use a loop
where
if we for example if we are taking 5
then the loop will go from 1 into 2 into
3 into 4 into 5 from 1 to that number
it's not
like if we are using from 5 towards 1
but we are going from 1 towards 5 the
answer will be same right because we are
multiplying all the numbers in both the
cases
so here we took 5 as the number next up
we have a variable f and the value of f
is also 1 as you know so here we are
using the do while loop for the first
iteration it will perform this so the
value of f for the first iteration will
be f equals to f into i which means f
equals to 1 into 1 which is 1
so the value of i will be increased and
it will become 2 and now it will check
for
while 2 is less than equals to n yes 2
is less than n so it will
again go up and it will update the value
of f
and the new value of of f will be 1 into
2 that is 2 then again the value will be
increased and it will become 3
and then it will
change the value of
f as well if it will become 6 and the
value of i will become 4 then it will
check if 4 is less than 5 yes 4 is less
than 5
and then it will multiply 4 with 6
because the value of f was 6 right so 4
into 6 it will become 24 and then
finally the value of i will be 5 and it
will check if the value of i is less
than or equals to 5 right while i is
less than equals to 5 yes that's true
because now 5 is equals to 5 and it will
again execute the loop and the value of
f will be 24 into 5 which is 120 and
then again the value of i will be
increased now it will become 6 which is
greater than 5 so it will come out of
the loop and it will print the factorial
of the number so let's save this program
so the factorial of 5 is 120
because see here we have used the
factorial of
n n is 5
and the factorial is 120 so if we
try to give any other number here other
than 5 let's say we are using here 10
save it
it says the factorial is
three six two double eight double zero
or it's 36 lakh twenty eight thousand
eight hundred so if you try to multiply
ten into nine into eight into seven so
on till two or we can say one the answer
will be this you can check it you can
google it or you can go through it in
your calculator
the typical definition of function
states that to work in a proper or in a
particular way
similarly functions in javascript are a
block of code that is used to perform a
specific task
in this particular video we will go
through the syntax and usage of
functions
so a function has a particular name and
we can reuse that block of code again
and again in our entire program
for example
let's suppose that we have to add two
numbers in a program that's a basic
program right sum of two numbers
so let's write the code first so we are
going to take a variable x and the value
of x will be 10
then again we are going to take a
variable y and the value of y will be 5.
lastly we are going to take a variable
total and the value of total will be
x plus y
so
the last thing
we are going to do is we are going to
print this on a browser
so here we are we are done with our
program we are done with adding two
numbers so let's save it and check the
output see the output here says 15
so what is happening is
the value of x plus y which is 10 plus 5
is stored in the variable total and we
are displaying total on a browser
so that's a very basic program right
now consider a scenario
where we have to do this addition for n
number of times at different intervals
so we have to perform the same task of
addition at different intervals so in
that case what we can do is we can copy
paste this same code repeatedly but the
length of the program will increase
because of that right and it doesn't
make any sense to copy paste the same
code again and again so this is where
functions come into play with the help
of functions we can create a separate
function to do this particular task and
we can call that function again and
again i'll take you through it so
basically a function has three parts
we'll go through each of them a function
has function declaration then it has
function definition and then finally it
has function calling
so we'll perform this same program of
adding two numbers we'll add two numbers
but this time we'll use the concept of
functions
so we'll use this whole code
we are going to use it inside the
function
so let's move on and see how the
function looks like how the syntax of
function looks like
so we use the keyword function
and then we have the function name
so let's suppose here we are naming the
function as sum
then we have the opening and closing
round brackets which denotes that this
is a function
this is the way to write a function
next up we have a pair of curly braces
for the body of the function so this is
the basic syntax of how a function looks
like
the naming convention for functions is
the same as we had for variables in
javascript if you guys remember we have
already discussed this naming convention
of variables
so this is the basic structure of a
function
so now we'll cut this whole code
and we'll
paste it here inside the function
right so we are done with it we are done
with our functions first part first we
declared a function with name sum then
we are done with the definition of
function
now what if we try to run this program
let's save this program and see it is
not printing anything on screen but if
you try to check out for any errors it
won't show any errors see there is no
error in this program
this is happening because we haven't
called the function yet right so to call
the function we have to write a single
word just write sum
with
opening and closing
round brackets and save it now now you
can see the output here is 15 so this is
known as function calling the program
already knows that there is a function
by the name sum
it will go and check for the same if the
function is there or not if the program
finds it it will execute the function
next up a function can also have
parameters what do i mean by parameters
is
we don't have to declare these variables
variable x and variable y here
instead of declaring them here we can
pass these values to the function
let's say we are passing x and y here or
we can pass a and b any variable you
want to pass you can pass it here
now we can remove this
variable x and variable y
we have to write here where because we
still need the variable total and next
up we have to pass the value for these
variables when we call the function so
we have to pass the values here let's
say we are passing the values as
and
so
let's try to run this program now and
see if it works let's save it and see
you can see here the output is 7
we can also pass strings over here so
instead of 4 if we try to pass any
string let's say we are passing
welcome 2
and instead of 3
will pass
simply code right now let's save this
program and see the output it says
welcome to simply code we don't have to
worry about the data type we'll use here
because javascript is a loosely typed
language right so the function will
automatically adapt to the data type
according to the value we will pass
during the function call
here in this code
variable x holds the value welcome to
and the variable y is having simply code
allocated to them dynamically so this is
what is known as
parameter passing in functions
let's move on and discuss the return
types in functions
so a function can also return a value
right now
we can see that a function is doing the
printing task what if we remove this
document.right from here and we'll paste
it somewhere else on the program outside
the function so we'll paste it here
right now the function will perform
addition only it won't print anything it
will just perform the addition let's
save this and see there's nothing so if
we try to check for error it says total
is not defined because total is defined
inside the function this is because of
the concept of local and global variable
we will discuss this concept in upcoming
video
so
here you can see it says total is not
defined right
so now what we have to do is we have to
write here
return
total
so now the function will return the
value of total outside
what this return statement does is
whenever we call the function as you can
see here we are calling the function
from outside and we are passing the
parameters as welcome to and simply code
right
so these parameters will go as x and y
and we are getting the concatenation of
welcome to simply code
right so when this return statement
comes into function
the value of this total variable will be
given out of the function
so there has to be a particular variable
to hold the value returned by the
function
we'll
use a variable here let's say we are
using the variable output
and in the rhs we are calling the
function so we have an equals to between
the lhs and rhs that's because when we
are calling the function it will return
a value and the assignment is done from
right to left in the case of an
assignment operator if you guys remember
we came across this
that whenever we are using an assignment
operator
the assignment will be done from right
towards the left
so whatever value the function will
return upon calling will be assigned to
the variable output
in this program we are passing welcome
to and simply code right so let's change
these two values now we'll change them
to a numerical value let's say we are
using here
and instead of simply code we'll use
here 15 and we are going to print here
output on the browser because the
variable output is holding the value
returned by the function right so let's
save it now and see the output is
50.
okay guys so this was the syntax
demonstration of functions in javascript
with a quick small program the
javascript is a loosely typed scripting
language right that means we don't need
to specify the data types every time
so a variable is basically a container
that can store data values those values
can be changed
whenever needed in this particular video
we are going to discuss the scope of
variables in javascript so what does
this scope mean in variables so scope
refers to the life of a variable in a
program
there are basically two types of
variables present in javascript local
variables and global variables
depending upon where we are creating a
variable variable
may have two different types of scope so
let's have a look at these two different
types of variables with the help of
examples
let's say we are creating a variable
here let's say we are creating a
variable
where a and the value of a will be 5
so we have created a variable here and
let's print the value of this variable
in the browser so what we'll do we'll
print this value in the
browser
so let's print the value of this
variable on the browser so here we have
printed the value of variable a so here
you can see the value is 5.
so we can print the value of this
variable anytime and anywhere in our
program right so if we try to copy this
line from here and we'll paste it
somewhere else in a program let's say we
are pasting it here so if we try to save
it now see here you can see that we have
two values of a because we have printed
a twice here right once we have used
this a here then we have used this a
here so here you can see we have two
values of a five and five so this
variable a is a global variable which
means its life is available throughout
the entire program or the entire script
we can say
and when we declare a variable inside a
function that variable is known as a
local variable for that function so
let's try to do it as well we already
know what functions are as we saw in the
previous video right so what we'll do
we'll make a function here let's say we
are creating a function
function
my function
opening and closing round bracket and
the body of the function right so let's
declare a variable here let's say we are
using a variable where x and the value
of x will be 10 right let's try to print
this value
so we have created a function here now
we are left with the function call only
so let's call the function here
but we'll do we'll call my function
right
save it and now here you can see the
output is 10 5 and 5 so if we comment
these three lines if we remove these
three lines and we'll save it now so
here you can see we have the output as
10 only so this variable x which is
declared inside a function so why it is
a local variable because if we try to
access this variable from outside the
function it is not possible so let's
cut this line from here and let's try to
paste it here so now what we are doing
is we are trying to access this variable
from outside the function let's save it
now
let's save this program now and see the
there is no output in the browser
because a local variable can be accessed
only in that function we can't access it
from outside of the function
so this is happening because as soon as
the function is executed the variable
gets destroyed means there is no
variable present in the memory now
the same thing applies to the memory
whenever we run a javascript program the
whole browser is present in the ram
or we can say in the memory so these
local variables are created only till
the function is executing once the
function is done running the same
function wipes out of the memory
whereas the case is different for global
variables so global variables are
available throughout the script they
have a global lifetime which means that
they will exist throughout the program's
running or we can say until the tab is
open
the next exciting thing about global
variables is
that we can access global variables from
inside the function so what we'll do
let's
cut this line from here
and we'll paste it
here
so now what we'll do we'll declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
a variable where y and the value of y
will be
15.
copy this line
and paste it again now what we will do
we will try to access y from inside the
function
so let's save the program and see the
output here is 10 and 15. 10 is the
value of x and x is a local variable for
function my function because we have
declared x inside the function whereas
variable y is a global variable we have
declared it outside the function and we
tried to access it from inside of the
function right so we tried to access y
here and we can see the value of y is 15
which is printed on the browser this is
what global variables are one more
exciting thing i want to mention at the
end of this video is if we declare any
variable in javascript without using the
where keyword so if we try to declare a
variable here let's say we are declaring
var1 okay we have not used anywhere
keyword so what we are doing is we are
declaring a variable and the value of
where one is 15. so we don't need the
where keyword separately when we are
declaring a variable however some of the
newer versions of web browser have some
sort of issue if we try to declare a
variable inside this function without
using the var keyword
so let's try to access this variable
let's try to access let's declare it
inside the function
okay what we'll do is we'll
declare this variable inside the
function
and will come in this line and what
we'll do is we'll try to access it from
outside the function right
what we'll do is
we'll write here
var1
save this
and see if
you don't understand it let me change
the value of where one let's change this
value to 20 save it now and see the
output here is 10 and 20. so where one
is a variable which is declared without
using the wire keyword right so we can
access this variable from outside the
function as well any variable which is
declared without using where keyword is
a global variable keep this thing in
mind guys we came across the different
types of data types present in
javascript
in the previous video where we came
across the types of primitive data types
in javascript
we discussed number string and we had
boolean null and undefined right so
these are the five types of
primitive data types present in
javascript
we know that strings in any programming
language are used to store and
manipulate textual value a string
contains a sequence of characters
written inside double quotes
so let's declare a basic string here
let's say we have a variable
and we have a variable as where x and
the value of x will be a basic string
let's say we have hi there as the value
okay
next thing we'll print this on a browser
document.write and we'll print x on a
browser
so this here is a string that holds a
textual value right suppose we try to
find the type of the variable x so
i hope you guys are aware of that if
you're not then please go through the
previous video on data types in
javascript let's print this value on
browser first
so here you can see it says hi there so
this is a string and let's try to
determine the type of variable x and
we'll see if it returns a string or
something else we'll do it with the help
of type of operator right i hope you
guys remember that so let's try to use
type of operator here
and
here we'll use
type of x
so let's
save it
and see
here you can see we have a string as the
type of variable x so strings are
helpful for holding data that can be
represented in textual form so let's
move on to a first topic for today and
that is escape sequence in javascript so
if you guys ever noticed that in the
previous few videos we use a lot of html
tags in javascript right for example we
use the heading tag so often
like when we are using the
document.write to print anything on the
browser we use heading tag quite a lot
right so the thing to notice here is
that these tags behaves as html tags
right we use them inside the double
inverted commas just like strings but
they still act like html tags so let's
understand this with the help of an
example
what we'll do is we'll remove this code
we'll print a simple
statement in a browser so we'll use
document.write
and we'll write here hi there
and we'll use a
tag
right so a basic html tag we are going
to use
let's say we are using the break tag i
hope you all are aware of the break tag
so the next sentence will be
so here in this example we tried to
print a sentence and we are using the br
tag right so let's print it on the
browser
so we are using the break tag in between
the sentences we have hi there and we
have welcome to simply code
so
we use this break tag
in a string right so the output
what we were expecting was hi there and
the br should be written in
string but there's a difference in the
output right the br tag is actually
functioning as an html tag
so here the break tag works the same as
it did for html so with this we can
conclude that if we try to infuse any
html tag inside the javascript statement
it will act as that tag only
so let's move on and we'll look at some
other types of escape characters present
in javascript
so
let's say we want to print this line
okay we'll
edit this one only so what we will do is
we will remove this break tag and
suppose we want to print this on screen
so we want this on our screen and we
want the welcome to be inside the double
inverted comma in output as well so if
we try to run this program now there
will be nothing
in the browser let's try to check if
it gets any error so here it says uncut
syntax error it says missing after the
argument list
so how to print this on the browser we
want to highlight the word welcome
so if we try to run this program as it
is it's not working right
to do this type of task we have the
backslash escape character
to print the double quotes inside a
string we use a single backslash with a
double inverted comma the syntax is we
have to use this backslash before the
double inverted comma so now if we try
to print this on browser here you can
see it says hi there and welcome is
written within double inverted commas
right
so that's how you can print this on a
screen next up if we want to use a
single inverted comma we have to use a
single backslash with a single inverted
comma so just like we did here with the
double inverted comma similarly we can
do it for single inverted comma as well
what we'll do is we'll copy this
document dot right and we'll print it
here
so here what we will print is
we'll print here it's all right okay
so we are using here a backslash with a
single inverted comma now we'll write s
the output will be it's all right
so
we have to use them because
we need them in a program at times right
so to avoid any confusion one must know
how to use this sequence character in
javascript let's save this and see
if we try to comment this line
let me comment this to make it more
easier for you to understand let's save
it now and see it says it's all right
you can't print it in similar way
without using the backslash escape
character
lastly if we want to put a backslash in
our string if we want to put a backslash
we want to show it in the browser so the
syntax for that will go like
we have the document.right right so here
we will write
the character
and we'll use two backslashes
is called
backslash
so let's try to print this
so here one thing you can notice
only a single backslash is printed on
the browser the first one is used as a
backslash escape character and the
second one which we have used will be
printed on the browser
we have a few more escape
sequence present in javascript like the
backslash n or we can say newline
we don't use them quite often i'll let
you know if we use them in future so for
now it's enough for escape sequences
present in javascript let's consider a
scenario where we have a collection of
similar types of variables suppose we
have a list of cars
let's create a small list here for a few
different car companies let's say we
have a variable where carbon
and the value of carbon will be
let's say
honda
okay and then we have another variable
let's say car 2 and the value of car 2
will be kia
and finally we have a variable let's say
where
car three
and the value of car three will be let's
say
ford so here we have taken three
different car manufacturers we have
honda we have kia and we have four and
we have three different variables right
so if we want to print all three of them
what we have to do is we have to use the
document.write method right so we have
to use the document.write again and
again
so we can do it for this small piece of
code right let's print the value of all
three variables here let's say we are
using document
dot right and we will print the value of
all three
variables so here we have printed the
value of all three variables right we
have carbon the value was honda we have
honda here we have kia and we have ford
as well
so this task is a bit simple for this
small piece of code right now imagine if
we have hundred values here instead of
just three values or maybe we can say we
have thousand values in a list we can't
follow the same procedure in that case
right
that's where arrays come into play what
we can do is we can use a single
variable and we can store as many values
as we want inside a single variable
by doing this we don't have to access
each and every variable separately while
printing them the data types of those
values present inside the array does not
matter at all so we can save either
numbers or strings or a value with any
data type we'll discuss it in a moment
let's try to define an array here first
so the syntax for array goes like this
we have to take a variable let's say
we'll declare an array here
let's say we are taking a variable where
car
and these opening and closing square
brackets represent the array it means
that it is an array if we are using them
in a variable inside this we can use
double quotes with the value we want to
insert it will go like this let's
suppose we have three values here right
we'll use these three values only we'll
use honda kia and food so to insert
these three values we have to follow
this syntax
so let's say we have the first
manufacturer as honda the next one we
have is
kia
and the last one we have is
four right so we have all the three
values here present inside a single
variable so we have a single variable
where car and we have all the three
values we have honda we have kia and we
have four
so
we can insert as many values as we want
like if we have a list of hundred car
manufacturers we can insert them in this
array now let's print the output of this
array so the output will go like we will
copy document dot right from here
paste it here
and
the output will go like this
so we don't need this piece of code
right now so we'll comment this
so that we can understand the difference
between these two codes
and now let's save this program
and see here you can see we have all the
three elements of the array we have
honda we have kia and we have ford as
well
so an array is a non-primitive data type
or composite data type
with one single name and can hold
multiple values here the array name is
car and it stores three similar values
right here we have three string values
we have honda kia and food so this array
can store
any number of values we want to store in
that array
so what if we want to print a single
value from these three values we have we
have honda here and 4 right so if we
want to print kia let's suppose so it's
easy to print this on a browser all we
need to know is the index number of that
value
so the index number in the case of
arrays starts from zero and
goes further
so we have three values here
as we can see so the index value
for these variables will be so for honda
the index value will be 0 and for kia
the index value will be 1 and for 4 the
index value will be 2.
so the index value starts from zero and
goes on further so one thing to keep in
mind guys whatever number of values an
array is holding the last index value
will always be one less than the number
of values so as here you can see we have
three values right so the index number
of the last value will be one less than
three
it means the index number will be two
because the index number starts from
zero
let's try to access the element present
at index 1
so we have kia here right all we have to
do is we have to put square brackets
here in the document.right here we have
to put square brackets
and we have to write the index value
inside of these square brackets so if we
write here one and if we save this
program now so here you can see we have
kia only it will print
the element present at index number one
so here in this particular case it is
kia
we can also loop through this array
using the index values let's say we want
to print each element on a separate line
every time right so we can use the loop
here i hope you guys are aware of the
for loop by now we'll write here so
we'll
we have declared an array so we will use
the for loop here and we will print here
for
will take a variable i
and the value of i will initial value
will be 0 and then we'll give the
condition the condition will be i less
than 3 because we know there are three
values only and it will go till 2 only
because it's going for the index value
and the final condition will be i
plus plus
so here we'll
use the curly braces
because this is the syntax for for loop
and the i value will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2.
so the same thing goes for 100 elements
as well we can use the for loop to
access all the 100 elements in separate
lines
so guys if we save this and here you can
see okay
it is printing kia kia and kia because
we have
particularly mentioned here cars present
at index one so we have to remove one
here and we'll save it now
so the document.write syntax will be
changed a bit we will write here i
and
if we save it now so we have all the
three values here you can see guys the i
value here will iterate through the
array and print all the values present
at indexes till the index 2. so the same
thing goes for 100 elements as well we
can use the for loop to access all the
100 elements present in the array
we can use the same iteration concept
for doing so
so guys there's another way to represent
an array in javascript it goes like this
we have a let's say we have a variable
this time we'll take the variable as
where fruits
so the syntax will be like new we have
to use the new keyword and then we will
use
new array
and we have to give a space here and the
elements we want to store inside the
array so we'll use a apple then we have
let's say
banana and finally we have let's say
mango
okay
and we can access the elements of these
array with the help of a for loop we can
use the similar for loop here so if we
copy this for loop from here
and we'll paste it here
instead of cars
will use a
fruits
right and we'll give the value as i
because we want to
iterate the variable i through each
index so we have once again the index
value as 0 for apple one for banana and
two for mango
let's comment this program as well so
that it will be easy for you guys to
understand
let's save this program now
and see we have the list of all the
elements present at array fruits so we
have apple we have banana and we have
mango printed on our browser so this way
of array representation or declaration
is less recommended because the other
way which we discussed earlier like when
we discuss the car manufacturers so that
way is a bit easier to use
so i'll recommend that way only because
this way is a bit tricky as well
so let's move on to our next topic of
discussion so if you know guys errors in
javascript work differently when
compared to other programming languages
like java and c plus so errors in
javascript have dynamic nature which
means we can add or remove elements from
an array at runtime
just like we saw the string methods in
the previous video for arrays also we
have a few methods like if we want to
add elements into an array or if we want
to delete an element from an array we
have the push and pop methods available
to do such tasks
to add an element into an array we use
the push method and the syntax for
pushing elements into an array goes like
so we'll
remove this piece of code
and we'll use the first one only the car
manufacturer
so if we want to push something inside
the array
right
we'll write here the variable name dot
we use the push method and we'll push
whatever value we want to push let's say
we are adding another car manufacturer
let's say we are adding nissan
we have to change the value here as well
because what will happen we have used
the condition i less than 3 so it will
check for indexes still index 2 only it
won't check for index 3 so if we write
here i less than 4 it will check for
nissan now let's save this and see a new
value is pushed into the array which is
nissan
so let's move on and discuss the pop
method so the pop method in array
removes the last present element from
the array if we use this pop method here
it will remove nissan in this case so
now you can see we have four car
manufacturers present in a array so if
we use the
pop option now if we use car dot pop and
let's run this program
and see it says undefined this is
happening because as you can see we have
pushed the value nissan into our array
so an
address in the memory location was
reserved for that particular
element now if we pop out that
particular element so if we try to use
cars.pop once again let's save it now
and see it removed the
element ford as well so
let's try to push one more
value in this particular scenario let's
say we are pushing a value as
hyundai and now let's run this so you
can see here it has inserted hyundai in
place of food because we have used the
pop
method to put food out of our array
so i hope you guys understood this so
these are the different methods for
arrays in javascript which are already
predefined to do some specific task
like this sort method if we write here
card dot so here are all the methods
here are all the array methods present
in javascript so if we use this sort
method what it will do it will sort the
array in ascending order
the array.length property so just like
we had the length property in strings so
we have the property in arrays as well
the array.length property is used to
find the length of the array so if we
use it in a for loop in place of this i
less than 4 so
here you can see we have used i less
than 4 now if we write here
array dot length so if we write here
car
dot length so
now we don't have to change this value
again and again so if we are inserting
any value or if we are removing any
value from this for loop so if we are
removing any value from this
array so we don't have to write here 3
or we don't have to change it to 4 every
time we insert an element we don't have
to change that value basically what will
happen it will check for the length of
the array so the length here is
let's say we have the length here 3
right so it will check for the length
and it will be one less than the length
of the array so if we run this program
now it will work fine i hope you guys
understood the concept of array methods
present in javascript the other main
difference
array has in javascript which makes it
different from c plus plus or java is we
can add elements with other data types
in javascript we try to use the push
method to insert a numeric value here in
this car's array so we will push another
value let's say we are pushing car dot
push and this time we will push
a numeric value let's say we are pushing
here 20.
so let's save it and here you can see
the value 20 is inserted inside the
array car
so we can
use
any data type inside a array in
javascript so let's take a scenario here
and let's say we have a piece of code we
are taking a variable let's say where
car manufacturer
and the value of this car manufacturer
will be rd a string right
next up we have another variable let's
say we have a variable car model
and the value of this will be let's say
car from od is q7
then we have another variable let's say
where price of this car
and the price will be
let's say
50 000 us dollars all right next up we
have a function
let's say we are using a function
that is all wheel drive
so we are having a function all wheel
drive
the opening and closing curly braces for
the body of the function and inside this
all wheel drive function we are using
document.write
and here what we will write
we'll write let's suppose
this car comes
with
quattro all-wheel drive
quattro i hope you guys are aware of
this word quattro it means that four
wheel drive
next up we will call this all-wheel
drive function here
so here is the data about a particular
car from a particular brand audi right
so the car model is q7 and the price of
this car is 50 000 us dollars so these
are the three different things we are
storing for a car of a particular brand
next up we have a function which states
the capability of the car the function
here is the all-wheel drive which means
that this car comes with four wheel
drive instead of general front wheel
drive or rear wheel drive
so this function is the behavior of the
car right
it shows that the car is four wheel
drive things are pretty sorted here
right we have the data about the car and
a function associated with it so let's
save this and we can see the output here
the car comes with quattro all wheel
drive so this is a basic piece of code
right
we have been through functions we know
how to use functions we know how to call
them so that's quite easy for now right
the problem occurs when we have a list
of cars let's say that we have to
maintain 100 different cars with all the
data of car manufacturer
we have car model price and then we have
different behaviors for different cars
not all cars have the all-wheel drive
property so
what we will do in such a case where we
have to use the same property again and
again for 100 different cars or 100
different entities we can copy paste
this same piece of code repeatedly and
we have to change the value every time
we copy paste it so we have to change
the variable name the car manufacturer
the car model and the price as well
imagine we are doing this for a list of
cars then it goes on and on so this is
the most inefficient way of tackling
this problem right
this is where the concept of objects
come into play
these objects help us to bundle all
these properties and attributes about
one particular entity if we talk about
this particular example of a car we can
put all these properties and many other
properties like car weight we have car
color and so on
together under
one name and make it an object
let's move on to the syntax for objects
in javascript we'll do it for this same
program we'll use objects now let's go
ahead and have a look at the syntax for
objects
so before we start there are few ways in
which we can create objects in
javascript we are going to discuss two
different ways of doing so
the first one is the literal way also
known as the literal object way
so the syntax for literal object way
goes like this
let's say we are declaring a variable
where car and
curly braces so these curly braces
represent that this car variable is
actually an object
inside this
we will define all the cars properties
that is whatever data we want to store
about the car like car manufacturer car
model and price in this particular
scenario so let's use them here so we
have
car manufacturer
and the car manufacturer is
od
right
next up we have car model
car model is
q7
finally we have the price which is
50 000
so you can identify the difference here
inside the object right when we declare
a variable we usually use the equals to
sign for assignment but here in objects
we use the colon and we are using commas
here because we have some more
properties so these three are the
properties for this object car we have
three properties associated with it we
can also add this all wheel drive
function inside the object and when we
use this function inside the object it
will be called a method whenever we use
a function inside a class or an object
so it is known as a method keep this
thing in mind guys so that syntax is
also a bit different when it comes to
methods inside an object the syntax for
that will be
we have to write here all wheel drive
and we'll use the colon then it is a
function so we will write here function
with opening and closing round brackets
and the body of the function
so what we want to write here is we want
to we want this function to return the
value right we want this function to
return this value so we'll
copy it from here
and we'll paste it here
so we want this function to return this
value so we'll write here return instead
of
document.write now this function will
return this string that this cars comes
with a quattro all-wheel drive
so if you want to change this string a
little bit you can change because we
have already
used this string in the previous program
we did so let's suppose
we'll write here
four wheel drive now this will be easier
for you to understand this
so this is what an object looks like our
object is entirely ready what we did
here is we bundled all these things and
coupled them we bundled all these things
we bundled
all the three variables we bundled this
function we bundled all of them together
inside a single variable and now this
particular variable car is an object now
if we want to access these properties of
the object like car manufacturer car
model etc whatever properties we have
here so what we have to do is we have to
use document.write so it is quite simple
so after this object we'll write here
document
dot write
and to access this object what we have
to do is we have to use the
object name with the dot operator and
the property name so if we want to let's
suppose
we will use here
car dot and property name will be car
underscore
manufacturer
so here is the syntax the syntax is
quite
easy you can see here we have used the
car object with the dot operator and
then we have the property name whatever
property we want to access
so let's save this program now and see
here it says od
by using this dot operator we can access
any property of the car not just a
property we can access the method as
well so if we want to access the method
like if we want to access this all wheel
drive function
we can do it simply by writing here car
dot and we'll write here instead of this
we'll write here all wheel drive and
we are good to go so if we save this now
so here you can see it says
this car comes with four wheel drive so
it is quite easy to access these
properties of an object so we can do it
by using this now suppose we call this
function normally with the
document.write inside the function in
place of return so if we write here
document.write
it's normal like how we normally call a
function so if we write here
document.write inside this function and
we can call this function by the normal
method like if you are calling this
function from outside what we will do
will write here car dot
and the function name
so if we save this now here you can see
the string is printed on the browser
this car comes with four wheel drive and
you can see here we didn't used any h1
tag or h2 tag so
you can spot the difference right
so that's how you can call the method of
an object from outside this is the
normal way
so now you guys might be wondering what
if we want to add more cars into this we
can copy paste it again to do so and
change the value of properties again it
is the same thing we can do with the
variables so this is where the following
way of creating objects come into the
picture
in which we use something different
known as object constructor that's a bit
different from other object-oriented
programming languages so don't worry if
you don't know about it also in the
newer versions
javascript supports the concept of
classes and object
so what we used to say earlier is
javascript is an object oriented
scripting language because it does not
supports the concept of classes and
objects fully but now the scenario has
changed javascript do support the
concept of classes and objects but we'll
keep it a bit simple so let's comment
this code as well
and we'll use this code for reference
so we'll comment this that's why we are
not removing it but we can remove this
piece of code
so let's remove it
and let's
move on to user second way of creating
an object
now we will create multiple objects
using a single template which is known
as a constructor function
let's have a look at the syntax for this
method so we'll write the function
keyword and we have named this function
as cars and in parenthesis we will
provide the
properties as parameters so these are
the properties we have car manufacturer
we have car model and we have car price
so these are the properties which we
used in the previous code as well so
here we have also used these properties
so we'll keep it that way only now
inside a function these parameters are
known as arguments so if we talk about
the naming convention so these
parameters are known as arguments
so let's move on to the body of the
function and inside the body we will use
this keyword here
this keyword refers to the object it
belongs to so here in this program this
will refer to the object basically
so what we are doing here is whenever we
are creating any object using this
constructor function we will pass
specific values like the car
manufacturer car model and the price all
of these values so all these values will
be present at the rhs so let me write
this first let's say we are using this
dot and the property name car
manufacturer
will write here
car manufacturer
so all these values will be present at
the rhs and the actual property of the
object will be this dot car manufacturer
so
this is the actual property of this
method you will understand it much
better when we create the object for now
let's mention here the other two
properties and method as well so
let's
use the other two properties which were
this dot
car model
and
we'll write your car model the last one
was this
dot
price
we'll write here price
let's add the method here as well inside
the constructor function we'll use this
keyword again to add the method the
syntax will go like this
we'll use this
dot all wheel drive
and this is a
function so we'll write here function
with the opening and closing round
brackets and then we have the body of
the function
inside the body of this function we will
write
whatever we have written in the previous
program so we'll copy it from here and
we'll paste it here
right so this is a complete constructor
function now using this constructor
function we can create multiple objects
of this car type so this constructor
function works like a template or like
the classes work in other languages like
c plus plus and java
so let's create an object here
so we'll create a variable here let's
say we are creating a variable c1 now
we'll use the new keyword
and along with the
constructor function so we'll use your
cars and we'll pass the values for all
the three properties so here you can say
we have the car manufacturer as od and
next up we have the
model as
q7 and the price is
50 000
okay so we have created a variable we
have passed the
values for the properties
and now
if we want to access this function if we
want to access this all wheel drive
function we can access this as well we
have to write here c1 dot all-wheel
drive and this is how you can call a
function
if we save this program see here it says
this car comes with four-wheel drive
so if you change anything here let's
suppose we are using here h2 tag
if we save this program now see you can
see the change here so we are calling
this function here and this will be
printed on the browser so this string
will be printed on the browser
let's create another variable here let's
say we are using where c2
and the syntax will be same for this as
well we'll write here new cars and we'll
pass the
values here so let's say we are using
bmw
and next up we have the model as
x7
and the price of this car is let's say
40 000 okay 40 000 usd
so
if we want to access any particular
property of any object like if we want
to access the car model or if we want to
access the car manufacturer so we can do
it the same way as we did previously as
we did in the literal object way so
to do so we have to write here
document.write
and it was quite simple so we have to
write here the object name dot
and whatever we want to print let's say
we are printing here car model so if we
save this now you can see here x7 is
printed on the browser because x7 is the
value of object c2 and let's suppose if
we want to
print here car manufacturer save it and
see here you can see we have bmw as the
output on a browser similarly we can
access the price as well let's save it
now and see here it says 40 000 so this
is how we can create multiple objects in
javascript we'll continue with the
previous program we made so
today we will use the literal object way
because this method of creating objects
is a bit easier than the other one we
discussed which was the constructor
function method so here we created the
car object which has three properties
car manufacturer car model and the price
of the car we have a method here as all
wheel drive when we use this method here
we use this method with the dot operator
and we
called that function we called that
method
with the help of the object
so the output was this car comes with
four wheel drive so this was something
we did in the previous video
if we talk about objects in javascript a
lot of things we know about in
javascript are basically objects like
the boolean values numbers strings and a
few more so many of these things can be
objects if we define them with the new
keyword basically any of the data type
other than the null and undefined can be
converted to objects or they have their
equivalent object forms if we define
them with the new keyword
so we have a few predefined objects as
well we have the math object the date
object and the regular expression are
also considered objects in javascript
a lot of things are objects in
javascript we'll use objects in dom
manipulation which we will go through in
further videos so that's why it is
pretty essential to understand the whole
concept of objects right so next up
let's look at how we can use different
data types as objects in javascript so
the syntax for using the basic data
types as objects in javascript goes like
this we'll declare a variable first we
have a variable str1 and next up we'll
write here the new keyword and the data
type so stringer is our data type which
we will be using as objects for now so
this is the complete syntax of how to
use a data type as an object in
javascript if we'll write here str 1 and
we'll use the dot operator so here we
can see we have the object methods as
well right
so i hope you guys are aware of the
methods present in javascript like we
had the string and array methods right
we have methods for object as well like
the index of method we have seen the use
of index of method when we went through
the string methods in javascript so
similarly we have the font color and the
length property for object as well so
length here is the property and other
which we can see are the methods for
objects in javascript so here this str1
becomes the object by default when we
use the new keyword with the string
while declaring
so there are few ways to determine if a
variable is an object or a primary data
type
so the easiest way to do so is to use
the type of operator so let's use it
here and check the type of variable str1
will write here
document.write
and we'll print the type of this
variable
so we'll use the type of operator and
the type of variable str1
so let me put it inside the h1 tag
so here we have written a type of
operator so let's print this value on
the browser if we save it see here you
can see it says object
if we write a string here in place of
this new string so if we
write here any string let's suppose we
are using a string here let's say we are
using
hello
okay let's save it now and here you can
see the type of this variable str1
changed from object to string so this is
the difference between a primitive data
type it was a string earlier but when we
use it with the new keyword along with
the string
and this is the basic syntax of how to
define a primitive data type as an
object so if we save it now here you can
see it is converted to object
similarly we can use the other basic
data types as well and
the other predefined objects we talked
about like the date object and the math
object will go through each of them in
separate videos so moving on let's go
back to our car object after we declared
the whole object we defined all the
three properties and the method also
somewhere in the program we realized
that we had missed a particular property
and we realized it after we have written
150 lines of code after this car object
so here you can see we have written here
150 line of codes so
i'm not writing 150 lines but let's do
it this way so we realized it after 150
lines
in javascript
we can add a particular property to an
object outside the definition also we
can add a property to an object anywhere
in a program
the syntax for that goes like this
we'll write the
object name
with the property name along with the
dot operator so we'll write here one
more property let's say we are using
car color
and the value of this
property will be let's say black
right
what this line will do is it will add
one more property inside this existing
car object so initially we had three
properties now this line will add one
more property to this car object we are
using the same name that is the object's
name having three properties over here
we are using the same object name here
you can see here the object name is car
and here we have also used the car
object name now we have added one more
property to this object car we can check
it let's print it out on the browser
so
what we will do we will write here
document
dot write
so here you can see we have used the
document.write method to print this car
color on our browser so we have used
here car.car color let's save this
program now and see
here you can see the output is black so
this is the property of the object car
now and if we comment this line let's
say if we are commenting this line
let's save this now and see here you can
see it says undefined we can add more
properties similarly like if we want to
add another property here we can go like
car dot and the property name whatever
property we want to add let's say we
want to add fuel type
so it can be a petrol car or a diesel
car or an electric car it doesn't matter
so we can add properties as well in fact
we can add methods as well so the syntax
to add method goes like we can add a
method here we'll
see it will go like car dot let's say we
are adding a new function let's say we
are adding the function new one
equals to and here we will write
function
so the
body of the function now whatever we
want to write inside the function let's
say this function return function
successfully
added
so if we try to call this function from
outside we can do it so let's try to
check out the output for this function
let's say we want to access this
particular function so save it now and
here you can see it says function
successfully added so the new method we
added is the new fun and we added this
method to our pre-existing object which
was the car object so i hope you guys
are aware of how to add a new property
or a new method to an existing object by
now what if we want to delete a
particular object so it's pretty easy to
do so in javascript we can use the
delete keyword object name and the
property name after the dot operator
let's suppose we want to delete car
model here we want to delete this
particular property of the object car so
what we'll do we'll delete this car
model
so the syntax for it is quite simple so
we'll remove this for now and we'll
delete a property let's say we are using
the delete keyword with
the object name dot method name or the
property name so we'll delete here
car model right
let's save it now
so this particular line will delete the
car model attribute of this car object
let's check it out and we will print
here the car model so
we'll write here car dot
car underscore model
and
save it now so here you can see it says
undefined and if we try to comment this
line and now if we try to save this
program so here you can see the car
model is q7
so this is how we can delete a
particular property or a particular
method from an object one more thing
before we wrap up this video is as we
all know javascript is a loosely typed
language right so we can change the data
type of these properties on the fly now
we will change the data type of this
property we had the price property right
so we'll change the data type of this
particular property now
we know that the value of the price
property is a number let's change this
number to a string data type what we
have to do is we have to write
so we have to write here car dot
price
and
update the value of here let's say we
are using 70 000 and we have to put a
semicolon it's the same thing we do to
update the value of a particular
variable right so if we try to print the
value of price now we'll get the output
as 70 000. let's try to print it on the
browser so we will cut it from here
we'll paste it here and we will print
car price
save it now see here you can see it says
70 000.
if we want to check the type of this
property
what we can do is
we can use the type of operator so we'll
use the type of operator
so this is the syntax of how we can use
the type of operator let's save this now
and see here it says string
earlier it was a number but now it is a
string so all these things can be done
dynamically in a program wherever we
want to do them so that's the benefit of
having objects in javascript today we
are going to take input from the user
with the help of a text box in
javascript
what we'll do is we'll create a text box
and any value the user will write inside
the text box will be stored in a
variable
and then we will print
that variable in
a message using the alert method or in
the control so whatever we want to do we
can do it
so let's create a small login page with
no styling because we will be focusing
more on the html and the javascript
parts so for that we have to go to our
html file so here is our html file
and we'll write here
input
and then we'll write here type is equals
to
name
and then we'll write here
placeholder is equals to let's say
enter name
this placeholder is an attribute that
gives a slight hint whatever value we
write here will be printed inside the
box so this enter name will be printed
inside this particular text box
so save it and here you can see on the
browser we have a text box here here you
can see how this value is written inside
the text box you can see here enter name
is written inside a text box indicating
the user to write the name here
so let's create another text box here
for the password we are creating a login
page right so we'll be needing name and
password so we'll use the br tag here
and then we'll write here
input type is equals to
password
and then we'll use a placeholder here
and we'll write here
enter
password this type attribute here plays
a vital role on this input element
because we have different types of
values we can use inside a text box like
we have numbers strings week time email
password and many more
so here we are using password
save it and you can see here we have two
text boxes over here in the browser so
we have a text box for name and we have
a text box for password
next up we need a button to perform a
task right
so we'll use the on click method along
with this button we can either use the
button tag or we can use the input tag
along with type is equals to button so
we'll write here input
type is equals to button
and
the value will be
say submit
or we can write here login as well save
it and here you can see we have a button
over here named as submit so we are done
with the login setup here we have a text
box for the name and one for the
password so we'll write any name here
you can see
let's write here caution and then we'll
write the password here let's say
any random password and nothing will
happen if we click on the submit button
so
let's add some functionality to this
submit button here so we will go back to
our html file and we'll write here
on click
so we'll write here a function name
print fine
we'll create this print function now so
we'll go to a javascript file
and we'll create a function here so
let's say function name is
print
and then we have the body of the
function now this function will be
called whenever we click on this button
so whenever we click on this submit
button this print function will be
called now we want this button to do
something right we want it to perform a
certain task what we want to do is we
want the user to write their name and
password and we will print this name and
password in the pop-up with the help of
alert method so we'll use the
document.getelementbyid method for this
task let's give those elements their ids
so we'll give these two input tags their
id so we'll write here
id is equals to let's say
you name or username and then we have
the password for password we'll give the
ids you pass fine save it and then we'll
go back to a javascript file
now both these elements have their own
ids
we'll use them in the javascript file so
we want to use the values given by the
user right for that we will create two
variables here inside the function print
to hold the reference of original values
so for that we'll write here
where x is equals to
document.getelementbyid and then we have
the ids you name for the username and
then we'll write here dot
when next up we'll take another variable
let's say whereby and then we'll write
here
document dot
get element by id again
then we have the ids
you pass
we'll write here dot value now what we
did here is we use the ids to get the
reference of those values which the user
will input you might have noticed here
that we have used the value property
here after the ids so this value
property returns the value attribute of
any text box
now we have the values here present
inside variables x and variable y the
next thing we want to do is we want to
print these values right so for that
we'll use the alert method so it's quite
easy to use we'll write here alert
and then we'll write here
the name is
and then we'll print
x so because variable x is holding the
value of name
then we'll
use slash n and after that we'll write
here
the password is
and then we'll print the value of
password
so we are done with it we have printed
the values of x and y here now save it
and now we will enter the values here
let's say the name is
caution
and the password is simply code
the moment we click on this submit
button there will be a pop-up with a
message
you can see it here
the name is caution and the password is
simply code we printed these variables
here along with the alert method
so this is how we can take input from
the user in javascript so we already
discussed that we want to create a login
form here with a specific name or
password right let's say we want the
user to be allowed only if the password
is simply cool otherwise the user should
be restricted from entering the web page
so this is a simple task all we have to
do here is we have to use the if else
control statements
so for that we'll write here after this
statement we'll write here if and then
we'll write here
let's say pass we are doing it for
password right so we'll write if y is
equals to is equals to
simply code then we have the
body of if we will write here alert
login successfully
and then we'll write here else
this
the statement will be
alert
wrong password
so we'll keep this line here so what
will happen is the moment will press the
submit button it will go to the if else
statement and it will check if the
password entered by the user matches the
correct password or not so if the
password matches it will print login
successful otherwise it will print the
wrong password and then finally it will
print the name entered by the user and
the password as well so let's save it
and we'll write here the name as let's
say caution
and the password let's say the password
will be different this time we'll write
here
simply learn
so this password does not matches the
original password right the original
password is simply code so what we are
expecting is it will return wrong
password here so let's save it the
moment we press the submit button you
can see here we have a pop-up with
message wrong password because the
password we entered is simply learn so
if we press ok here in the next message
you can see the name is caution and the
password is simply learn fine
so
let's do it again this time we'll enter
the correct password we'll write here
simply code
and we'll change the name as well so
let's say the name is
rahul
submit it and here you can see we have
the message as login successful
we will press ok and here you can see
the name is rahul and the password is
simply code in this tutorial we will see
how we can use radio buttons to take
input from users
now html radio buttons are created with
the help of input tags and the type for
creating radio buttons is radio we can
use radio buttons on multiple occasions
for example we can create a quiz
question
using a radio button at one time only a
single radio button will be selected and
we can use it to find the correct answer
so today we will use radio buttons along
with the id attribute and then we will
create a javascript function to find the
correct answer for a quiz so without
wasting any time let's move on to the
programming part
so first we will see how to add radio
buttons to a html document
in the html file we will write here
input
type is equals to
radio
and then we have
value is equals to let's say option one
because we are using multiple options
right we have multiple options for a
single question or we have multiple
options here so we'll write value as
option 1 and
then we'll write here the value we want
to print so we'll write here option
fine
save it and we have a radio button over
here you can see we can check it and
it has no functionality till now
so let's add another button first so
what we'll do we'll copy this line from
here and
we'll paste it and then we'll change the
option as option two and the value also
is option two
right save it
again and here you can see we have two
radio buttons now
let's add a submit button here first so
we'll
write here
input
type is equals to
button and then we have
value is equal to
submit save it and here you can see we
have a submit button as well one thing
you might notice here is we can check
both the text boxes right we can check
option 1 and option 2 both at the same
time so if we want to select only one
check box at a time we have to group
them so we'll use the name attribute and
the same name for these two radio
buttons so the name will remain the same
for both of these
radio buttons so we'll write a name is
equals to let's say
g1 and
then we'll write here as well we'll
write a name is equals to g1 now these
two radio buttons belong to the same
group
save it and now if you try to check both
these boxes you can see we can't do it
now because we have grouped them and now
we can select only one radio button at a
time right
now the next thing we are going to do is
we'll move to a javascript file and
we'll create a function there so we'll
move to a javascript file so here's our
javascript file and we'll create a
function here so let's do it first
so we'll write here
function
let's say the function name is
fun1 fine and then we have the body of
this function so inside this function
we'll write here we'll take two
variables again for both elements so
we'll write here where x and then we'll
write here document dot
get element by id then we'll write here
the id so let's provide the id to those
elements as well so we'll write here
before name will provide the id so let's
say the id for
the first radio button is red one and
the id for the second one will be
let's say red two fine
save it
and we'll go back to our javascript file
we'll write here red one
and then we'll take another variable
we'll write here where y is equals to
document.getelementbyid method
and then we'll write here the id so the
id for the second radio button is
red 2. fine we don't need the value
property here next up
we have to use the if else statement to
print something right so we'll write
here we'll use the if else statement
we'll write a if
and then we have
x dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will
return something right so we have a
condition here as if x dot checked is
equal to is equals to true this
particular statement will check if the
radio button whose reference is
available at variable x is selected or
not this dot checked is the property for
a html element if the radio button is
checked the output will be something so
let's add the output here as well so the
output will be if the radio button is
checked
it'll be like we'll write a alert then
we'll write here the
option
selected
is
then we will write here
x dot
value so it will print the value of x as
well
now we have another condition here
we'll write here if y dot checked
is equals to is equals to true
then it will return the option
selected is we'll write here plus y dot
value we are doing this because we have
three different conditions here right if
we select option one or if we select
option two or if we are not selecting
any of these options right so we have a
else condition for that and then we'll
write here
else so here we have to write elsif
and then we'll write here else
and
else part will print
alert no option
selected save it
and
let's do one thing first we'll call this
function with the help of onclick method
so we'll go back to html file and we'll
write here in this element we'll write
here on click and we'll call this
function on click
so we'll write your fun one and we have
this function here save it and here we
are good to go
so
if we move back to our javascript file
you can see here we have three
conditions either x is checked or y is
checked or none of these are checked so
let's
check the output now we'll select option
one first we'll submit it and here you
can see we have the output as the option
selected is option one fine
press ok then we'll refresh this page
and we'll select option two and now
we'll press the submit button so here
you can see on
selecting option two we have the output
here as the option selected is option
two right
so what if we are not selecting any of
these two radio buttons so
click the submit button here and you can
see we have the output as no option
selected so i hope you guys got it now
the syntax will remain the same if we
want to create a quiz so next up what we
are going to do is we are going to
create a quiz so here is the code if you
want to create a quiz on your own so we
have a question here we have a question
as javascript was developed in the year
and then we have two options for it we
have 1998 as first option
so if we go here you can see we have the
first option is 1998 and then we have
another option is 1995.
obviously we know the answer for it as
1995. we'll change the function name
here as fun one
and save it
the javascript file for this code will
look like this so we have three
conditions here again if x is checked
then the output will be wrong answer and
the correct answer is
y
and then we have another condition for y
if y is checked or we can say
if 1995 is check we'll have the output
as right answer and then we have another
condition if none of these radio buttons
are checked we have the output as no
option selected so let's see if the code
works fine
so save it
and we'll go to the browser so we'll
select option one first so we'll select
this 1998 submit it and here you can see
we have the output as wrong answer the
correct answer is 1995
right we have the value of
y here the value variable y is holding
is 1995 so we printed it over here and
we have the output as y dot value which
is 1990
so if we refresh it and if we select
1995 here then we'll press the submit
button and here you can see we have the
output as right answer fine press ok and
we are going to do it again so this time
we won't be selecting any of these
options we'll just click on the submit
button and we have the output as no
option selected fine i hope you guys
understood it
in the last few videos we discussed the
same thing right we saw how we could
take input using text boxes and then we
saw how we can take input using radio
buttons today we are going to grab
user's input with the help of a select
box in javascript so without wasting any
time let's move on to the programming
part directly first we'll see how to
create a select box in html and then
we'll move on to the javascript part so
let's move on to html and we'll create a
select box here if you guys remember we
used the input tag in the previous few
videos for text boxes and radio buttons
but for the select box the scenario is a
bit different
we have to use the select element in
html so we'll write here
select
so we have the select element here we
have to use this for select box in
javascript or in html
so this select box is used to create
drop down list of some elements so we
can add as many elements as we want to
that list so we'll use the option tag
for each component we are going to use
so the code goes like this we'll
start with the select tag
and let's save this and see if it makes
any changes to a browser so you can see
it on the browser that we have a button
over here now we'll add options to this
drop-down list
for that we'll use the option tag we'll
write here option
and let's say we have three options we
have three car manufacturers name so
let's say the first name is bmw
then we'll copy this
statement and
we'll paste it again and again and then
we'll change the name of manufacturers
so let's say another manufacturer is
already and the last one is
food
fine we have three manufacturers now
save it and you can see it over here we
have a drop down list of three different
elements we have bmw audi and ford here
next up we'll add a button
so a submit button as we did in the
previous few videos for that we will
write here input type is equals to
button and then we have value
is equals to
submit fine
save it
and we'll use a br tag here
save it now and here you can see we have
a drop down list here we have a select
box here and then we have a submit
button over here
fine
now we want to print the option we
selected by clicking this submit button
for that we have to add functionality to
our html document right so we'll follow
the same steps as we did in the last
video wherein we used the
radio buttons and the text boxes so
we'll write here inside this input tag
we'll write here on click so what we
want to do is we want to call a function
on clicking a submit button right so
we'll write here a function name so
let's say the function name is
selected
and we have to use the id attribute in
the select element right so we'll use
the id attribute here we are not going
to use a id attribute inside the option
text but we are going to use the id
attribute inside the select text so we
will write here id
is equals to let's say
fine
so we have a id here now we have to use
the value property here as well so i
hope you guys remember the value
property which we discussed in previous
videos so the value property is used to
access these values right so we'll write
here
value is equals to
bmw and then for audi the value will be
od and then for ford the value will be
four fine save it and here we are done
with the html document so next up we'll
create a function in the javascript file
so let's move on to the javascript file
and we'll create a function over here
so we'll write here
function and the function name is
selected
then we have the body of this function
right so we are going to repeat the same
steps we are going to take a variable x
which will hold the reference of select
statement so we'll write here
document
dot
get element by id and then we'll write
here the id so the id is 1
so now we have a variable x which holds
the reference value of select element
right
now we have used the document.get
method to get the reference of the
selected value next up we'll use some
properties for select element while
printing the value with alert method
so if you guys remember in the previous
video wherein we used the dot checked
property for radio buttons
so similarly we have some more
properties here for the select boxes as
well so let's have a look at them
so we'll write here
alert
and then we have a property which will
go like this we'll write here x dot
options
and then we have
this brackets and dot value
so this options property here is a
collection of all the options we have in
our select tag
we have multiple options right this
property works on arrays so we have an
array of all the elements and we can
access any of them for that we will
write here the index value right so
let's say the index value is zero we
want to print the element present at
number one
so we'll save it and the moment we press
submit button you can see here we have
the output as bmw now one thing to
notice here is
it doesn't matter which option the user
chooses the output will remain bmw for
all those cases because we are using the
first element of the array so no matter
which option the user is selecting the
message will be there with the value
present at index 0.
so we can say now that we can't use
static values right we can't use 0 1 or
2 here because we want
to provide the value dynamically because
we have three different values here and
we want to print the value which the
user selected not the one present at
index 0 1 or 2. so for that we have
another property here we have to write
here x dot
selected
index
and one thing you have to remember is we
have to write here x dot selected index
or any variable we are using here so we
are good to go now
save it
and if we press submit now while
clicking on bmw so our first option is
bmw let's press the submit button and
here you can see we have the output as
bmw
and next up we'll be selecting od and
we'll press submit so here you can see
we have the output as od now
and finally we have ford as well so
let's check it as well so press the
submit button and here you can see we
have the output is food
so this is how we can take inputs in
javascript from drop-down lists next up
we'll go through a simple program as we
did in the last video wherein we'll
create a quiz question and we'll check
if the option selected by the user is
correct or not so this is the code for
that so we have the question here is
javascript was developed by we are using
another question different from the one
we used in the last video so we know who
developed javascript right so we have a
question here javascript was developed
by and then we have two options for the
same question the first one is brendan
ike and the second one is guido vin
rossum
so then we have the ids one for the
select element and the values are also
the same
then we have a button over here which
will call function one on clicking
and if we move to a javascript file we
can see here we have a function fun one
and then we have a variable x which
holds the reference of value
returned by
document.getelementbyid method
and then we use this
value so we have used a x dot option so
what we are doing is we are basically
checking that if the selected value is
equals to brendan ike or not if the
value is equal to brendan i then the
output will be the answer is correct
else the output will be the answer is
wrong
so let's save it and we'll move back to
html file and we'll save this file as
well so now here you can see we have a
question over here and we have a select
box which has two options brendan i can
guide oven rossum right
so let's select brendan i first press
the submit button and here you can see
it says the answer is correct fine
next up we are going to
use geido van rossum and we are going to
press submit button so here you can see
the answer is wrong
we have been using the
document.getelementbyid method for the
past few videos right
we know it is used to access an html
element with the help of an id which is
uniquely provided to each element
so we use that method with text boxes
then with radio buttons and then with
select boxes as well
so today we are going to use a method
that is somewhat similar to
document.getelementbyid method
so we'll be using the
document.getelements by tag name method
in javascript
as the name suggests this method is used
to access a bunch of similar elements
with the same tag so we have tag name in
our method right so we can access a
bunch of tags with similar name like if
we have a few div tags present in our
program and we want to change each div
text style we can do it with the help of
this method
so we'll look at the syntax first and
then we'll move on to the difference
between id and tag name method
so let's move on to the programming part
directly
what we'll do is we'll create a few div
tags first and then we'll change the
style of these div tags with specific
styling properties we are not going to
use css for that but in javascript we
have other styling properties as well so
we'll be using those styling properties
so let's create the div text first
we'll write here div
and then let's say we are
writing it this is section
one so we'll copy this line
and we'll create four similar div tags
right
we have section one two three and
four
save it and you can see over here we
have four different sections present
now this is a very basic example and
here we have different sections present
right next up we'll try to access these
div tags with the help of tag name
method so let's add a button over here
and then we'll move on to the javascript
part
so we'll
write here
let's use the br tag and we'll write
here
input tag again we'll write an input
type is equals to
button and we'll use the on click method
as well so we'll write here on click
and let's say a function name is
fun2
and then we have the
value of this button as let's say submit
close the input tag and save it so here
you can see we have a button over here
submit button and you can see here
nothing is happening on clicking on the
submit button
so next up what we are going to do is we
are going to add functionality to this
submit button for that we have to move
to our javascript file and we have to
create a function over there
so we'll write here
in the javascript file we'll write here
function
fun2 and then we have the body of this
function right so the syntax is a bit
similar to that of the
document.getelementbyid method what
we'll do is we'll take a variable x and
then we'll write here
document dot
get elements by tag name and then we'll
write inside the brackets the name of
tag we want to access right so here we
have added four different div tags so
in this case we'll write here div and we
can similarly access any of the tags
present in an html document we can
access paragraph tags we can access
anchor text and any tag we want to
basically
so
save it and here now we have a variable
x that holds an html collection of all
the div text present inside the html
file
this means that we have an array of
references of all the div tags here
inside this variable x
so if we try to make changes in a single
array element just like we did in the
select box example wherein we use the
array index to access a particular
element present at a particular array
index right so we can do the same here
we'll write here x and then we'll write
the
index number so this particular
statement will access the element
present at number one
or this particular syntax will access
the first div tag of html document
because we know arrays start from 0
and at 0 the first element will be
present so this div tag will be present
at number 0
and then we are going to use the style
property so we know that
x here is not a variable only actually x
here acts as an object and we know that
different objects have certain
properties in javascript so style is one
of those properties and next up we'll
write here
let's say
font family so what we are doing is we
are doing the css part with properties
present in javascript so let's say we
are changing our font to
courier new all right so this is a font
name
and we can use any font name over here
so save it what will happen now is on
clicking the submit button
the font of this particular section the
font of div 1 will change to courier new
so let's try if it's happening or not on
clicking the submit button you can see
over here the change between this line
and other three div tags clearly the
font has changed the new font is courier
new and what we did here is we changed
the font family of this particular div
tag so similarly we can make more
styling changes to other div tags as
well so let's do it here
and we'll make changes to each of the
div tags we have in a html file so let's
say
here we are using the color property and
we want to change the font color to
blue
fine then we'll do the same for element
present at number three for that we'll
write here x and the index number will
be two
so then again we'll use the style
property and then
let's say we are writing here font
style
fine and the font style we want it to be
italic
and then finally we have one more
property
let's say for a
for the repeat so let's say for the last
div tag we are using the background
color
fine
and we'll write here the color name is
red
so we are good to go now save it and we
have four different properties over here
for section four we are changing the
background color so
three will be the index number of the
last
array variable so save it and on
pressing the submit button you can see
the change over here so for section 1
the font is changed to courier new for
section 2 the font color is blue let me
zoom it out a bit to show you guys you
can see over here the color is blue
and then we have italic text in section
3 and finally for section 4 we have the
background color as 4 right
so you can see how we are accessing any
particular element of the array now
why we are using these properties
separately for each array element
so if we try to make changes on each
element of the array we simply can't do
it in javascript at once so if we try to
write here so let's comment this out
first what we'll do is we'll write a x
dot style dot font family so basically
what we want to do is we want to change
the font family for all the div tags
present right because we know the
variable x is holding an array of all
the div text present in a html file
right so we'll save it and you can see
over here if we are clicking on the
submit button you can see nothing is
happening so if we go to our console
and you can see it over here that we
have an error here so it says it cannot
set property font family of undefined so
this is the problem with this get
elements by tag name method
to overcome this problem we have a
solution as well so the solution for
this problem is we have to use the for
loop
so how this for loop works
so we'll write here
for
and then we'll take a local variable i
and the initial value will be 0
then we'll write a i
less than
x dot length because we want to traverse
the whole array right and then we'll
write here the condition
i plus plus
so we are good to go then we have this
body of for loop and inside here we'll
write x and the index number will be i
because it will keep on changing and we
are in a loop
so
we'll write here dot style and then
let's say the style we want to
do is font
weight and what we want to do is we want
to make our font
bolder
fine
so comment this line as well save it now
and you can see over here everything is
clean now what will happen is on
pressing the submit button the font will
change the font weight will change
basically so let me zoom this
and if we click on this submit button
you can see the font is more bolder
right
so if we are using another property here
let's say the font
we are using here
background color and we want the
background color to be yellow
fine so save it and on clicking the
submit button you can see the background
color for all the div tags for all the
four section is changed to yellow fine
so this is how we can access all the
elements of an array at once
now what we did is we started a loop and
traversed every element in the array and
applied the same property to each
element
so this is how we can do it with the
help of
tag name method in javascript now what
if we have hundreds of similar elements
like div tag present in our website and
all of them are present at different
locations so let's try to do it and what
we'll do is we'll insert certain
different elements in between these div
tags
fine so we'll include a form and then
we'll include some radio buttons and
anything we want to do we can do it so
we'll add some more elements in between
these div tags
so here you can see we have inserted two
three more elements and between these
div tags so save it and you can see
after each section we have something
else here we have a form with
two different text boxes we have name
and age and then we have a submit button
as well
then after that we have section two so
this is our section two
then after section two we have radio
button and the value is a then we have
another radio button b and in between we
have all the div text present so
basically what we want to do is we want
to change the style for each of the div
tags right
so we will change the background color
here so let's say we'll write here red
and what will happen is on clicking the
submit button on clicking this submit
button what will happen is the
background color of each div tag
so the background color for section 1 2
3 and 4 will change to red so let's try
to do it and let's see if it's
working or not so we'll click on the
submit button and you can see it over
here we have all the div tags with
background color as
red so this is working totally fine
one more thing we'll discuss before
wrapping up this video is the uniqueness
of id attribute for each element so we
are saying this for a long time that the
id for each element should be unique why
so although we saw in the past videos
that we can use the same id for two
different elements when we did the same
for accessing a css styling property
using the id attribute but if we try to
do the same thing with javascript we'll
get an error for example if we try to
access the value of any particular
element with the id attribute but we
have two elements in a html file with
the same id so it will throw an error in
that case basically and this is the
reason why we use the tag name method in
javascript so that if we want to access
multiple elements of the same name we
can do it with this method because it's
not possible to use the id method
separately for each element present in
the html document right
because we have certain same html tags
present within an html document like we
have the div tags here similarly a
website is long enough to have multiple
similar elements present within it so
that's why we use the
document.getelements by tag name method
in javascript so guys in the past few
videos we use two different methods of
accessing an element from an html file
using javascript properties so we know
the difference between the id method and
the tag name method right today we will
use another method to access a
particular element in javascript that is
the class name method or we can say the
get elements by class name method in
javascript so before discussing the
class name method in javascript let's
look at why accessing an element is
important in javascript
so we know that the document object
model is used to change
add or delete html elements we saw
earlier that we could change html
elements or the css style of any element
in the document with the help of
javascript properties
so to make specific changes to those
elements we need to access them using
particular methods so we discussed two
such methods before the id method and
the tag name method right so let's move
ahead and look at the class name method
of accessing an element in javascript as
the name suggests the main attribute in
this method will be the class name so we
know the difference between the class
and the id attribute used in html
we know that id has to be unique for
each element but we know that many
elements in an html document can have
the same class right so we used class to
access specific css properties in the
previous videos
and that is the only benefit of using
classes in javascript so we can say that
a single class can be used by many
elements within an html document so
let's dig a bit deeper into this concept
so let's say we have five elements
present on our website and we want to
make changes in three of these elements
right so let's write the code here and
it will be easier for you guys to
understand so
we'll write here in the html file we'll
add five different
elements
so let's say we are writing here
div and
then inside this div we'll write
this is
section one
will copy this
we will paste it here
so we'll use two div elements and two
paragraph element right so here in this
p tag we'll write
this is
section three
and then we'll copy this line paste it
again copy this one as well and paste it
here
so we have section one section two three
four and
five
so out of these five different
elements we have three div tags and we
have two paragraph text so we'll discuss
why we have taken two paragraph text in
between the
div tags
so we are done with it here you can see
we have five elements present in our
html document three of them are the div
text section one two and five are div
text
and two texts in between are the
paragraph tags so now
let's suppose we want to change the
style of three of these elements let's
say one four and five so we can do it in
two ways right either we can use the id
method or we can use the class method
however we can use the tag name method
as well but we have to use two different
variables for that right that will be a
lengthy process why two different
variables because we have two different
tags present here right we have to
create separate variable for the div tag
and separate one for the paragraph text
so that will be a lengthy process so
we'll consider id method and the class
name method for here
so considering the id method the
document.getelementbyid method we have
to provide a unique id to each element
so we have to provide unique id to this
div tag then we have to provide to each
and every element here right because we
need to access
three of these elements so at least we
have to provide the id to those three
elements which we want to access right
so in such cases we can use the class
name method where we want to access more
than one element but not all the
elements in an html file
so we'll use the class attribute in each
element we want to access
so let's say we want to access section
one two and five
so we'll write a class let's say the
class name is cls1
we'll copy this paste it here and we are
accessing one two and four because one
two and five are
the div text so we can access these with
the help of tag name method as well so
we'll access one two and four
fine so we have used the class attribute
here
next up we'll create a button and then
we'll add functionality to a html
document so let's create a button here
we'll again use input type is equals to
button and then we have
on click
and on clicking it will call
func one
and then we have the value as
submit fine
so save it
and here you can see
in the browser we have five sections
over here we have section one two three
four and five then we have a submit
button which will call the function on
clicking so we haven't added
functionality till now so let's move
ahead to our javascript file and we'll
add functionality to our
html document
so inside this javascript file we'll
write here
function and then we have the function
name as
function
then we have the body of this function
so the syntax
remains a bit same
so we'll take a variable first and then
we'll use the document method to take
references of all the elements from a
html file
so we'll write here
where x is equals to
document dot
get elements by
class name right and then we'll write
the class name here so the class name is
cls1 till now what we did was we took
the references of all the required
elements and stored them inside a
variable named x in the form of an html
collection
so now we can make changes to these
elements and what we'll do is we'll
again use the style property to make
styling changes in those three sections
so we have these three sections present
inside an array and we can access any
one or all the three elements right so
we'll write here x and then we'll
provide the index number so let's say we
want to access section 1 that is the
first div tag so we'll provide the index
number as 0
then we'll write dot
tile
then this style is a property dot
then let's say we want
to
change the font style so we'll write
here
font
style
font style will be
italic save it so this piece of code
will change the font style of the
element present at index 0.
save it and on clicking the submit
button here on the browser
we can see the change in this section
right so if it's not visible so let me
zoom it a bit for you here you can see
guys the font at section one is changed
to italic right
so in this case we have all the three
elements present in our array and we can
make changes to each of these elements
so let's try to do it and we'll use
element present at index 1 now
we'll copy this line and we'll paste it
here again two times because we want to
make changes to all the elements right
we'll write it 2 and we'll write here 1
and let's say
we want to change the font color for
this one and the font color will be blue
for this we'll change the font weight
let's say
and we want to make it
bolder
so we'll write here bolder
save it and on clicking the submit
button you can see we have all the three
sections with some minor changes the
first one is changed and we have italic
over here for the second one we have
blue color as font color and for the
third one which is section four we have
the
font weight as boulder so you can see
the change over here so this is how we
can make change to each element
separately
and we can also make changes in all the
elements at once as well so for that we
have to use the for loop
just like we did for the tag name method
right
so for that we'll write here so let's
comment these three statements first
and then we'll write here
for and
we'll take a local variable here we'll
write you where
i is equals to 0 i will start from index
and i will go till
x dot
length
and then we have the condition is i plus
plus
so inside the body of for loop we'll
write here
x and
instead of index number we'll write here
i because we want to traverse the whole
array then we'll write here style
dot
and let's say the style we want is
background color
we want the background color to be let's
say
yellow fine
so this is how we can use the for loop
save it and we'll see on clicking the
submit button on our browser
the background color for all the three
sections that is one two and four is
changed to yellow
this is how we can use the
document.getelementsbyclassname method
to access all the elements present in an
html file with a particular class next
up let's discuss the difference between
the id method tag name method and the
class name method
so we'll discuss when to use which
method so
let's start with the id method so the id
method is used when we want to access a
single element and we have to provide a
unique id to that element in order to
access it so the id method is quite
useful when we want to work on a single
element
apart from that if we want to work on
more than one element we have two other
methods
we can either use the class name method
or the tag name method for more than one
element
so the tag name method is also quite
useful when we want to access elements
with the same tag name we can access all
the similar tags present within an html
document with the help of tag name
method the only problem is we can access
similar types of tags only at one time
we can't access two different types of
tags with this method
so this is where the class name method
comes into play we can access more than
one element with this method and the
elements can be different just like we
did here we had
div tag and paragraph tag right so
the section 1 2 and 5 are from div text
and the section 4 and 3 are from the
paragraph text so we can access two
different tags with same class name with
the help of class name method in
javascript so with this we came to the
conclusion that more than one element in
the html file can have the same class
and can be accessed with the class name
method so by now i hope you guys
understood the concept of all the three
methods which we have discussed
the
id method the tag name method and the
class name method in javascript we can
use any of these methods according to
our needs so guys we have been
discussing specific methods of accessing
an element for the past few videos
now today we are going to discuss
something different
before going deep into this topic let's
recall events in javascript so the
simple definition of an event states
that something that happens
so when we manipulate an html document
in javascript we try to do something on
the web page right so several events
take place on a website like the user
hovers over a specific element or clicks
on an element or pressing a key in the
website can also refer to events
or we can say submitting a form or
playing a video also refers to the same
thing so we are using the on click event
for the past few videos wherein we
discussed that a specific task would be
performed on clicking a particular
button what we did was we were just
calling a function by clicking a button
in html so clicking a button is also an
event right and the function that will
be called upon clicking the button is
known as event handler because that
function is basically asking the
computer to perform a particular task on
clicking the button
so like the on click event we have some
more exciting events present in html
which helps us make a web page more
interactive and responsive as well so we
can do it with the help of javascript so
we'll go through two such events today
the on mouse over event and the on mouse
out event so the onmouseover event will
perform a task when the user takes the
mouse cursor on that element similarly
the onmouseout event also performs a
task when the user takes the mouse
cursor away from that element so for
example let's suppose we have an image
present in our webpage and we want to
change the size of that image when the
user takes the mouse cursor over that
image and the image should get back to
its previous size when the user takes
away the cursor so what's basically
happening is when the user is taking its
mouse over the image or picture the
picture size will increase and on taking
the mouse cursor away from the image the
size will get back to its default size
so let's do it once and we'll see how
these events work within an html
document so first of all let's add an
image to the html file we'll use the img
tag for that and we'll have to provide
the path for the image right so we'll
write here
in a html file we'll add an image here
so we'll write here img and then we have
to provide the source
and the images are stored inside the
images folder in this system so we'll
write here the image name so we have
provided the path here next up what
we'll do is we'll use the alt attribute
so we'll write here
in the alt we'll write a simply code
fine
save it
and here you can see we have an image
over our browser but the image size is
quite large right so we'll limit the
size of this image using the width
property so what we'll do is we'll write
here width and let's say the width of
the image will be 250 pixel
save it and now you can see we have an
image over here the image is in its
normal size so this is the image so we
have this image over here and next thing
what we are going to do is we are going
to increase the size of this picture on
taking the mouse cursor over this image
so what will happen is when we take our
mouse cursor here the picture size will
increase so for that we have to use the
onmouseover property or we can say the
onmouseover event so what we'll do is
we'll write here onmouse
over
and we'll call a function on taking the
mouse cursor over this image so we'll
write here change size
so we'll declare it in a javascript file
and we'll call this function on taking
the mouse cursor over this picture
so next thing we are going to do is
we are going to
move to a javascript file and we'll
define this change size function there
so let's
go to the javascript part we will go to
a js file and we'll write here we'll
declare a function first so we'll write
here function change size
and then we have the body of this
function so
we can do it without taking any variable
like in the previous videos we were
taking a variable to store the reference
of
the id attribute so this time we are
going to use the document.getelementbyid
but we are not going to use a separate
variable for storing the reference so
we'll write here
document dot get element by id and we
haven't provided the id so let's do one
thing let's move back to a
html file and we'll use the id attribute
here as well inside the img tag we'll
write a id
let's say the id is
img one fine
save it and
will
right here inside the js file will give
the id here as well so we have the ids
img one
save it and the next thing we are going
to do is we are going to use the style
property with this
document.getelementbyid method so we'll
write here dot style
and then we'll write a dot width
and then we'll specify the width so
we'll write here the width as let's say
500 pixels the default width is
250 pixels right so save it and let's
see if it's working fine or not so here
is the image on the browser and we'll
take the mouse cursor over the image and
you can see the change in the size of
this picture so javascript makes it easy
to do such tasks now you might have
noticed that the images size remains the
same once the user takes the mouse
cursor away from the image right so the
image size is changed let me zoom out a
little bit so it will be easy for you
guys so what we'll do is we'll refresh
this page and here you can see on taking
the mouse cursor over this image the
change in the size of this particular
picture
so now the image size is 500 pixel
now the image size is not getting back
to its original size like what we did
was we use the on mouse over event and
the image size is changing and that's
working totally fine so the next thing
we are going to do is we are going to
use the on mouse out event and what will
happen is
the image size will get back to its
default size like which is the 250 pixel
so we'll
for that we'll use another function so
first we have to use the on mouseout
event here
so we'll write here on mouse out and
we have to create another function so
we'll write a change size 2 so this will
be a function name save it
and here we have to create another
function in the javascript file so we'll
write here function change size and the
function name is change size 2
then we have the body of this function
and we'll use the
document.getelementbyid method
the id is same which is img1 and then we
are going to use the style property
again
and this time we'll
specify the width as
250 pixel so this is the default
size of our image save it so what we did
is we created a function that will be
called when the user takes away the
mouse cursor from the picture and the
image size will be changed to 250 pixels
which was the initial size of the image
so save it
and now you can see here on the browser
the image size is changing on taking the
mouse cursor over the image the image
size is 500 pixel now and on taking the
mouse cursor away from the image the
image is getting back to its default
size right so you can see the change
here so this is how we can use these
events to make our web page more
interactive and attractive as well next
up we'll go through another example
wherein we will change the image on the
mouse over event and the default image
will be shown on taking the cursor away
from the image so this image will change
on taking the mouse cursor over it and
again it will get back to the default
image on taking the mouse cursor away
from the image so guys here's the code
for the same and what will happen is the
image will change on taking the mouse
cursor over it and gets back to the
default on taking the cursor away so
guys the html part will remain the same
wherein we use the img tag to add an
image and then we have two functions one
for the on mouse over and another for
the on mouse out event so in the
javascript file we defined the two
functions here so you can see the
function one is change image and the
function two is change image two so
what's happening is we are using the get
element by id method again and this time
we are using the src attribute and what
we are doing is we are changing the
source of image like we are using here
the simplylearn.png
so this is our image saved in the
particular folder inside the images
folder and in the next function what we
are doing is we are again changing the
image to the default image so we have
used the
simplico.png image here so what will
happen is the default image will be
replaced by this image when this
function is called and the other
function here will again replace the new
image with the default one so let's take
a look at the output and
save it
so
here you can see on taking
mouse cursor over this image you can see
the change so this is the image we want
to change so on taking the mouse cursor
away from this image you can see the
image gets back to the default one you
can see the image is changing and it's
quite responsive and attractive guys
inheritance is an essential concept in
any object-oriented programming language
inheritance refers to the procedure
through which one class or one
constructor inherits the properties and
methods of another constructor in simple
terms let's suppose we have a
constructor named as vehicle and we know
we have different types of vehicles
present like we have cars and we have
bikes as well so all these types share a
few things in common right now if we
want to create a constructor let's say
we want to create a constructor bike and
we want it to have a few of the same
properties and methods as of the
vehicles constructor
so in that case we are left with two
option
either we can copy the properties from
vehicle constructor and paste them
inside the bike constructor or we can
simply use inheritance to inherit those
properties from the vehicle constructor
to the bike constructor in this case the
vehicle class will be known as a base
class and the bike constructor or class
will be known as derived constructor
because we derived a few properties from
the vehicle constructor right
don't worry guys i know the concept of
classes might be new for you and the
concept of inheritance might seem a bit
different from other languages like if
you are coming from a c plus plus
background you may notice that there we
use classes for the concept of
inheritance but in javascript before the
introduction of es6 that is ecmascript 6
the concept of inheritance was based on
constructors and prototypes so with the
introduction of ecmascript 6 the idea of
classes was also introduced in
javascript and the usage of inheritance
was also changed we will discuss classes
and inheritance in the next video today
we are going to discuss the traditional
way of using prototypes for inheritance
so don't be stressed guys if you are not
clear with the syntax of inheritance by
the end of this video in the next video
you will understand the concept and
syntax of inheritance without any
confusion
so we'll now talk about a few things so
let's start with the programming part
so guys whenever we create an object
with a method like we can create an
object with the help of object literal
method or we can do the same with the
help of constructor function method as
well right
then we have a prototype every time you
might have noticed it we have been
through it in the past few videos so
every time we create an object we notice
that it has a prototype now what we will
do here is we'll create a prototype so
the syntax will be like so we'll write
here const we are using const in place
of variable i hope you guys are aware of
const where and let keywords so today we
are using here const so let's say the
prototype name is
employee
we'll write a equals to and then we have
the body of the prototype let's do one
thing now we'll use a method let's say
the method name is
post post of the
employee and we'll write your
function and then we have the body of
the function so let's say this function
returns a string so we'll write here
return
and let's say the function returns a
software developer and then we have
another function named as change name
and we'll write your function
will pass a parameter
and then we have the body of this method
so we'll write here this dot name
is equal to name and we are good to go
right
so what we did here is we created a
prototype of the name employee and it
has two functions one is the employees
post and the other one is to change the
name
so let's save this program and check it
in the console if it has any errors so
let's save it now and we'll go here and
check on the console
so here you can see
everything is fine so till now we
created a prototype now let's create an
object as well so what we'll do
we'll create an object here we'll write
here let's say where and let's say the
object name is even
so we'll
create an object with the help of
object dot
create method
okay so we have to write here dot
so we have to
pass
the
prototype name so we'll write here
employee and then what we'll do we'll
print this on a console so we'll write
here console.log
and we'll write here even let's say so
we created an object even with the help
of dot create method let's save it and
check it on the console if we see here
we don't have anything else other than a
single prototype
right we have a single prototype here we
have no method mentioned so if we open
it we have the two methods of course we
have post and we have change name but if
we write here let's say we are writing
here even dot name
and then value of name will be let's say
caution
and then we'll assign a role as well
let's see these are the two new
properties
we'll write here even dot rule and let's
say the
role of caution is
writer
fine and if we save it and check it
again on the console
now what we did is we changed the name
and rule right so these are the two
properties we have both name as caution
and rule as writer
now let's see if we can use the methods
here as well